at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
O hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday night what's the matter with
your [__] okay you got yeah there was
something else that was opened that is
just it's it's like a card for this show
but it's frozen oh okay okay yeah got
you got it though you're fine now yeah I
got the damn Command Module is [__]
operational yeah the Command Module this
this rickety operation we've got over
here I'm going to call this [__] a
Command Module yeah that does make it
sound a lot cooler doesn't it yeah said
oh you guys are a minute late I know
because Tom was showing me like a
trailer for a movie and I was like uh we
got to go on come on we were sitting
here but you know what that trailer for
that that movie a24 movie Civil War yeah
yeah cuz he was trying to show me this
actor that I know glasses yeah and I was
like [__] I I know who it is but I can't
think of his name right now but yeah so
we we we had a whole discussion about
Steve Bashi before the thing and then we
got off on that so you know what I mean
you know how that goes yeah we might do
a Steve Bashi
Marathon because we were discussing like
why it is that Steve bshi um despite not
being conventionally attractive is yet
somehow super sexy and I'm not the only
woman that says that like a lot of women
do I don't know if he's a good-looking
ugly guy or an ugly good-look guy like I
I wouldn't call him ugly it's just yeah
he just kind of get he's kind of funny
looking he's kind of funny look and and
they make he's also kind of hot at the
same time he can make [__] goofy
faces and that's really what you
remember him you remember him doing
these goofy ass faces there's a lot of
photographs of him in other movies where
he's like serious that [__] look
a gangster as [__] when he wants to you
know everything about his face he looks
like he's about to lay down some [__]
serious knowledge you know what I mean
I've always liked him and we saw like a
an old picture of him when he was real
young like when he was in his
firefighters uniform and I was like oh I
totally I would have been all over that
when I was that age yeah kind of my best
friend Mike Kowalski back yeah he was
like he was kind he was cute but like
kind in a nerdy way and I was kind of
like oh I'm all into that I like that um
so yeah it seems like a lot of people
here have not heard about this incident
and uh that we're going to talk about on
the show tonight which is good because
this is I had not heard of this either
which is crazy because I'm all about the
Unsolved Mysteries and [__] but somebody
recommend it might have been zanada
actually because he sent me um like a
documentary about it earlier there's a
there's actually kind of a lot of
documentaries about this on YouTube but
I feel like a lot of people haven't
heard of this one even though
everybody's heard of like de la of past
right yeah I would argue maybe this
one's weirder like it's kind of similar
well not yeah it's kind of similar but I
don't know I think it's weirder I really
know nothing about it I just overheard
some of the details but I didn't catch
the very beginning of it so I'm with you
guys in this one I'm just gonna be I'm
just GNA listen to Jen and trying to
come up with I think this one's weirder
yeah I already knew de pass I know what
that yeah I feel like every well yeah I
mean we talk about deav pass I feel like
everybody knows and it's like yeah it's
weird the way that that ended up and we
did a show about it a while back I'm
pretty sure that that was an avalanche
yeah yeah and cold weather they died of
cold weather too might have been one
thing they might have thought there was
an avalanche or Avalanche or something
like that I think they didn't natural
disaster but um the crazy [__] they were
doing at dat La fast you know and I've
been [__] cold as [__] up in Korea
Subzero weather hallucinating you know
me and other guys you know bad
hypothermia happening when you get
hypothermic you you you go crazy you do
all kind of crazy [__] you're you're
having hallucinations you think you're
hot you start taking your clothes off
yeah paradoxical undressing you call
that right and uh I got one I got
hallucinating one time I just started
walking off and my friend chafino
luckily he was warm enough to [__]
have go wait a minute where's he going
and he ran down there and got me says
where you going man I say I'm going to
McDonald's he goes dude we're in Korea
and I said it's right over there in the
middle of the woods said it's right over
there and I pointed to the top of the
hill over that was the [__] MD the
DMZ to Korea it's over there see the
lights and he goes dude man you got to
get back in bed I see the golden AR get
back in the I want some coffee yeah get
back in the get back was in bed it was a
sleeping bed get back get in the bag man
I was like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
would have frozen to death if nobody saw
you I just kept on walking yeah I was
going to go to McDonald's and get some
coffee I I forgot I forgot that I was in
the Army yeah yeah cold weather does
weird [__] yeah to your brain I was
living in it was like kind of like it
reminded me of um sleep paralysis you
know where you can see the room but you
see other things in the room that aren't
there at the same time your dream
material is right in with what your eye
is seeing right you know it's like that
that's what hypothermia is like your
hallucinations are being kind of
superimposed over reality it's a it's
kind of like um having late sleep
paralysis I guess but like you're awake
you know right you're awake yeah which
is [__] up and I wasn't cold which
that was very dangerous yeah well that's
why like people with hypothermia that's
you know paradoxically that's why they
call it that they start taking their
clothes off because they start feeling
hot which is I don't remember feeling
hot but I didn't feel cold right and I
didn't have my jacket on just got out
sleep sleeping bag started walking and
see that's always dangerous that's it's
kind of like it's kind of like opposite
when you're having a heat stroke yeah
when when it's dangerous is when you
don't feel hot anymore yeah then yeah
then it's then it's knows that it's then
it's gotten really bad he's like hey
Ross Ross and I just kept walking down
and I was walking down where the [__]
sector we were watching with rifle fire
so he knew I didn't know what the [__] I
was doing
he ran down there and got me yeah well
like I said it's a good thing he did
because you probably would have just
wandered off and frozen to death he knew
well we went to Bas together and they
wouldn't have known what happened they
would know what happened they would have
found I would even never even met you
yeah they'd have found me up in some
Mountain somewhere Frozen how'd he get
here been like what the [__] is going on
it would have been a mystery and people
would have been talking about you on
YouTube all these years later you know
what I mean that's crazy [__] I was
going to
McDonald's I want I wanted to [__] see
the lights I want [__] Egg McMuffin
yeah that is that so wrong yeah I was
like it's it's right over there go dude
we're in Korea there's no McDonald's
over there and I was like oh yeah yeah
that's right took to you yeah yeah was
weird uh Zach was saying that the same
thing that Steve Bashi has same thing
with William defo yeah exact yeah
William defo was also hot as F and Jack
Nicholson yeah Jack Nicholson much
hotter when he was younger even though
he was funny looking not to much now
that he's an old dude but um you know
yeah and Tammy said have you ever heard
of the twin flame cult I don't think I
ever have I need a piece of paper though
because I want to write that down so I
can put it in the next in a pole I
forgot I put paper over here usually I
would do that but okay I'm going to
write that down so I can put that in
there if you see Jack Nicholson any of
his movies when he was real young though
he was goodlooking guy just he was he
was just prematurely bald that was the
weird thing about him yeah I think
that's kind yeah sorry and he didn't
hide it he just said [__] it I'm B hit
the desk got that [__] crazy ass
[__] balding bald bald by the time he
was 30 yeah he was bald really young um
yeah Zan said Steve Bashi looked good
when he was a firefighter he did yeah um
and James naap said he has heard of this
case and it said it it is weirder than
de la of pass see I thought it was too
all right um and Zan said this is a
strange damn case I have my own theories
I do too um but we'll get into that like
at the end the outlaw pass was
hypothermia and people trying to save
the people who had succumbed to
hypothermia and then eventually the
hypothermia got them they all had
basically the same equipment so they all
started to go down around the same time
yeah
so windchill got him I
think yeah like I said and whether it
was a real Avalanche or they just
thought it was an avalanche I think that
was what caused them to like cut their
way out of the tents and when D probably
started hallucinating Avalanche and
[__] ran out ran out of the [__]
tent and people [__] follow and they
panicked yeah maybe panicked and follow
then then they had to get him out of the
tree cuz they were up trees and [__]
right yeah Elizabeth said is this the
case where they started getting sick
yeah kind of uh yeah that's what kind of
happened um somebody said did you guys
watch the show where Steve Bashi
investigates his family history no I
have not but now I have to see that
sounds that name kind of sounds
Czechoslovakian or not cakan what where
Steve Bashi yeah I guess investigating
his stanle yeah Italian yeah but he
looks kind of Polish or something I he
looks Slovakian I mean I'm assuming
that's his real last name but I don't
know yeah may may not be yeah Zan said a
lot of these cool Russian cases are
filtering out in the last 10 years yeah
yeah this one I mean as with any case
that comes out and this happened in the
diov P past case too where it's just
kind of like oh they were murdered by
the KGB or whatever and this one has
some of those theories as well I'm not
sure I don't know maybe I'm jumping
ahead I'm not sure I buy it now I will
say that it could be that they died as
result of Russian military stuff but not
like on purpose that's all I'm going to
say about it but we'll get into like
yeah it's cool that now that the Soviet
Union's gone for you youngsters you have
no idea what the [__] we're talking
about but now the Soviet Union is gone
everything's about it we're starting to
find out more about it and you know me
growing up in a military academy and
then being in the military and being on
duty when the when the burlin wall fell
and then the Soviet Union
collapsed I saw all that from inside the
middle military machine as it was going
on and um the Soviet Union was far more
interesting than we thought it was cuz
man you couldn't get any information
about it just rumors we see you know
fantastic migs
tanks rumors of how big their military
was rumors about how good-looking
Russian girls were turned out that was
true a lot of stuff about it was true a
lot I found out that a lot of things
that we were told in the military and
just in American society were not true
about the Soviet
Union um you know just little stuff the
det the details were wrong um we didn't
realize how really how in the end their
their mentality was a lot like Americans
they were real skeptical of what was
going on there were years of [__] uh
strikes happening and resistance and
then the [__] thing fell apart
overnight military just
vanished um our military was doing stuff
on the down low with the Russian
military to get nuclear weapons safe and
man it was weird go to Fort Cavell and
you see Russian hind helicopters and
rushing equipment there mysteriously I
guess they were just giving it to us but
uh they were running around and I guess
testing it using it trying to figure out
you know if it was any good or not weird
SF was involved with all that special
forces but uh it's all starting to
leak uh of how their system set up and
even find out find out about their
serial killers uh and then these weird
cases like this yeah and this like I
said this is super weird I think I mean
I think I know I'm not going to say I
think I know what happened but I have my
I have my favorite theory about all the
theories that happened I figure it out
yeah we'll see like I said just just let
me lay out all the [__] let you lay it
out first because don't CU I know how
you tend to like just jump to stuff
after I only say two facts and I'm like
dude I have like a million more facts
you uh Z says by the way have y'all ever
done a show on the is doll woman case
from Norway yes I think we did it might
have been um an ESPN one we I think we
did a show about is allom and Summerton
man like a long time ago cuz remember we
I think we did another show on Summerton
man recently because he was identified
was is doll the girl that was dead out
on the campsite yeah yeah and she was
like burned yeah and all her and then
they found all the and then they found
all the stuff back in the hotel room
that had like all those wigs and
passports and stuff e East German oh she
was for sure a spy
yeah most most spies are female or that
that kind of situation they're female
and they're sex operatives
they're they try to talk their way into
these guys that have information they
start sleeping with them and then they
uh they sell the girl information they
usually know what she is half sometimes
they don't though sometimes they don't
sometimes they're that St sometimes they
just sometimes they think it's it's
really their girlfriend friend but no it
isn't yeah so James sex James snap said
yeah I'm on the same track like for what
I said about what I think this this
might have been I mean just from what I
I don't know I I have theories about it
um let's see and then uh they were
saying episode five was um the ISA woman
when okay yeah yeah um and Jen says I
don't know this case I didn't know about
it either until zanada said about it but
like I said there are a bunch of other
videos about it that are super what was
the other case of the of the East German
East German sex operative the girl that
was found dead in the was it in a hotel
or was it yeah that happened in osow I
think I can't remember what year it was
I just saw like the beginning of a video
about it yesterday cuz it came on after
something yeah I don't remember 70s or
60s I thought it was 60s but it could
have been later remember I don't
remember if we did a show about that but
I think there was we did we see like an
Unsolved Mysteries or some [__] like
that about that case saw that was pretty
weird too saw some British saw a British
material on it it was like from it was
from the BBC I think back in the day
yeah their
investigator was when they found her she
was they found her dead she had a 9mm
pistol yeah I think it was a brownie
high power actually I think been a long
time and this guy this British guy knows
nothing about guns evidently he says
well she wouldn't have been having that
for self-defense you don't need you
don't need that kind of gun for
self-defense I'm like go tell [__]
millions of Americans everybody's
carrying a nine here he he didn't know
what he was talking about I guess he
thought that for self defense you carry
things that are smaller you know 9 mm
for Warfare or something you don't never
go to war with a pistol man it's always
going to be something like a missile or
a tank an assault rifle but uh I just I
remember he threw that out and I man
[__] tripping they gave her a [__]
clean weapon that's what they did a
weapon that couldn't be traced it
happened to be
9mm women have carried them forever they
carry them in [__] holsters and you
can conceal
one Juan says happy Wednesday you too
how are you we're awesome how are you
you doing uh and xan said yeah it was is
doll woman Summerton man and number
stations one of your first EP yeah we
did like an Espionage show that was a
fun show we should maybe do a revisit on
that but you know if there was updates
in the case and stuff like that yeah I
think number stations are the thing of
the past now well yeah yeah but there a
lot of people think they were creepy and
we talked about what they probably were
on there which it's not that mysterious
but they are still pretty creepy yeah
internet has got rid of all that and
cell phones
um te kilip says uh I'd be over the moon
if y'all did a show on margorie Kong and
the Glen Sheen murders here in MN that's
Minnesota right is that Minnesota or
Montana uh I don't know I think that's
Minnesota it's Montana is I think I was
all those M States man I always like
forget what's the case marjerie conon
and the Glen Sheen murders I don't know
that one yeah I haven't heard of that
either so yeah I wrote it down though
okay I'm going to I'm putting on I have
a huge list still [__] that we'll never
get around to but you know what I mean
we'll we'll probably get around to that
one of these days Zan said I don't want
to spoil anything but I think me and
Jenny came to the same conclusion yeah
we probably did I mean it seems like the
most likely there's other [__] that
could have happened but like the most
likely thing we'll figure it out um yeah
the girl that checked in under the last
name fairgate I think yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think that's that same girl
yeah I just like I said I was just
reminded of it like the other day cuz I
was actually watching a video about this
case and the channel had done a uh a
video about that case that came on after
I just didn't watch it all I think the
fairgate girl killed herself didn't she
well they said that she did but it
almost seemed like well they they said
that she did but I wasn't it something
like well she would have had to hold the
gun just like that which seemed a little
unlikely but you know I mean you can but
you know they just thought it was a
little bit
weird uh Elizabeth said have we done the
Springfield 3 I don't remember if we did
I thought we did I thought we did but
I'd have to look back and uh you know
how can wait a minute I can't see CU
that little heart is in the way how can
I send you a book on it oh um you could
actually if you really wanted
to um just message me on Facebook or
Instagram probably Facebook would be
better because Instagram sometimes I
don't see them um and I'll give you the
home address if you want because that
would be cool if you sent me a book
about it but uh yeah so do you want to
get into this yeah let's hear about this
case because yeah you I'm sure you'll
have theories about it there's lots of
theories at the end and I have them all
like in a list in a numbered list you
know what I mean yeah we got people
there yeah so we can get started yeah
okay like I said most people heard of
dew of past but I think maybe people
haven't heard of this one as much and
this one to me I think is weirder I
think it is
weirder so this happened in August of
1993 so not as long ago because de law
pass was 1959 right so this was like a
lot more
recent so here's the thing you have it's
also it's usually called thear Deb
incident um Kamar Dean is the name of
the mountain range where it happened but
it's also called the uh Corina or corova
incident which is the last name of the
woman that was the leader of the group
you know what I mean so This Woman's
name is and I'm know I'm going to
pronounce all these names wrong so I
apologize but her name was uh Ludmilla
corova and she was 41 years old and she
was a hiking instructor very very
experienced
very um well-known like in the area she
was also like a survivalist so she was
like a teacher she had like a lot of
pupil and stuff like that and she would
take them out on these hikes and teach
them survival stuff and everything like
that um and had attained the level I
don't know if it was official but a lot
of her students and stuff like that like
called her master she was like Master
Level you know what I mean now one of
the things that she was known for that
some people complained about but her
students mostly didn't
um she was kind of known as being maybe
a little bit of a hard ass um I think
she would have call it called it tough
love um cuz she would pretty much like
push them to their limits you know what
I mean and a lot of her students as
we'll see in this particular incident
were a younger were teenagers you know
what I mean so sometimes I think that
there were some parents of the students
that thought that she was pushing the
kids too hard it doesn't seem like her
students ever complained though um they
liked it and really like a lot of her
students said she was a great teacher
and really like changed their lives like
for the better like taught them
confidence and like taught them how to
survive and you know it just made them
good at everything you know what I mean
so a lot of them like really appreciated
her so she was seen as like being a
really good teacher who really like knew
her [__] you know what I mean so the
summer of
1993 um yod Milla had um planned this
hiking trip with six of her students and
they were going to go in into the Kamar
deban mountain range which is not too
far where they were heading off from was
not too far from um utk and like real
close to like the Mongolian border right
now she had been to this area before was
pretty familiar with it and this area
where they were hiking was not remote uh
it was actually a real popular tourist
spot and considered real safe for hikers
even like there were different Trails of
different difficulties and stuff
obviously but um there was a lot of
trails there for like beginner hikers
and stuff like that so it wasn't
considered like dangerous or anything
like that and there was just like always
people around um you know especially in
the summertime which this was and at
this particular time that they were
going on the hike there was actually the
something called the terata tourism
Festival going on so there were even
more like tourists and hikers and
canoers and kayakers and stuff like that
in the area than there normally would be
you know what I mean so what I'm saying
is this wasn't a case of like some
hikers going to this [__] Wilderness
where nobody was like there was just
tons of people around this was a real
popular
area so her students had actually
planned with her for this trip trained
for the trip for like six months like
prior to them going um and these were
all students that she had known for
quite a long time so they were all quite
close um now the first of the six which
was probably like the closest to her I
feel like was a 23-year-old man named
Alexander uh Christen who was actually
known as Sasha now he actually I believe
that he started doing classes with her
when he was 12 so they had like a
motherson kind of relationship like she
really considered him like a second kid
you know what I mean pretty much cuz
they you know she'd known him for like
half his life um so the other five were
you had a 24-year-old woman named
Tatiana filipenko who was actually the
least experienced she had been on some
hikes before but nothing of this
magnitude 19-year-old uh Dennis shackin
uh he was actually only going because
somebody else had dropped out like at
the last minute and he had wanted to go
really badly so at the last minute they
were like hey this there's a spot do you
want to do it cuz he was like the second
or whatever and he just like left a note
for his parents it's like hey I'm going
to the mountains bye you know what I
mean which is kind of sad because
spoiler alert he didn't make it so um so
yeah actually none of these people made
it except for
one so you also had um 17-year-old
Valentina udko who was sometimes called
Valia and you had a 16-year-old uh
Victoria valsova and a 15-year-old named
Tamor banov like I said most of them
were experienced hikers some of them had
never been on a hike this strenuous
before but all of them had been on ones
like going up to the this level so this
was going to be a challenge for them
they had been training for it for 6
months and everything like that they
knew their [__] like I said so you know
even the ones that were
younger so they get to this Village
called Marino like at the where the kind
of the trail head was on August 2nd
1993 so the particular itinerary that
they were planning on following was
considered now I've seen different
sources on this some said because I
think in this area like um you know how
they have like levels of difficulty like
for the hiking trails some sources I saw
said that this Trail they were on was a
three which is like medium difficulty
but some of them said it was a four
which is a strenuous difficulty you know
what I mean I don't know if it's just
like a four step so this was like the
hardest I've heard it was like one step
down from the hardest so like strenuous
but not the worst you know what I mean
so I'm not really sure but it was you
know it it was challenging not for
beginners is basically what they were
saying now they had checked the weather
reports like as you do before this and
the forecast had been um the the weather
was supposed to be perfect like it was
supposed to be sunny uh temperatures
were supposed to be higher than average
maybe it would rain a little bit but
that was it it was supposed to be clear
skies it was supposed to be like amazing
right now interestingly there were two
other hiking group groups in the same
area that LOD milla's uh group was doing
one of these groups was actually led by
lud milla's daughter whose name was
Natalia who was 16 so like she had grown
up doing this kind of stuff she was
leading her own groups now so she was
taking a different Trail than her mom's
group now what they had planned to do
was that both of them were taking a
different itinerary but they were going
to meet up like a few days in like on
August 5th and then they were going to
do the rest of the Trek together right
spoiler alert that's not what happened
but you know what I mean that's what
they were supposed to do so her daughter
was out there in the same area as her
and there was another group out there
too who I don't think were related in
any way but they were also out
there so they get started on the hike
start going up the mountain first couple
days went amazing uh they were like even
way better than they were expecting like
the weather was amazing like they made
really really good time um you know they
got farther than they thought they were
going to get all this other kind of
stuff so they get up to this one Peak
whose name I can't even begin to
pronounce you know what I mean some of
these Russian names I'm going to have a
hard time so that went
fine however on August the
4th as they started going down like the
other side of the
mountain it turned out that this weather
forecast that they had gotten was
complete
[__] because um there was an
expected
storm some called it I've seen it some
called like a um what do they call it
not a tornado but a um what's that other
[__] word that they say over there
[__] now now I can't remember the word
for it blizzard no not blizzard it
wasn't snow necess NE well there was a
little bit of snow but it wasn't exactly
like that like I said this is summer
it's the top of the mountains there is
kind of snow up there but yeah but it
was like it was a bad bad storm so it
was like days and day like days of heavy
rain there was snow horrible horrible
like gale force winds like so hard that
like some of the trees were like knocked
down you know what I mean um some of the
other hikers that were in the area cuz
like I said there was a lot of people
around um said that there was like real
bad fog they called it sticky fog you
know what I mean which that should tell
you something right there so the weather
was like real bad is what I'm saying and
the um forecasts in no way had predicted
this so they were kind of like well [__]
okay this isn't great you know
so on this day they're kind of like
going through all this weather and
they're like holy crap this like really
sucks you know what I mean it like
obviously really slow them down right so
they stopped for the night at about 4:
in the afternoon um you know it had
started raining really hard all of their
gear was wet uh so you know everything
was heavier cuz so they were all really
tired from like carrying it and the
tents they had were also kind of wet and
you know so they tried to like set up
they couldn't make a fire for a while
because everything was wet like I said
now interestingly the place where they
stopped and a lot of people have kind of
brought this up as being odd the place
where they stopped to Camp was kind of
like and there's photos of it because
there's some photos of the expedition
that they
took seemed like it was kind of like a
big open
field and some people are like well they
were experienced tigers and experienced
survivalists why didn't they go like
under the tree cover or you know say
like why did they set up camp like in
the middle of this open field like when
in this shitty weather I'm not really
sure why um and it turns out too I'm not
sure if they entirely knew this but
about a 30 minute walk from where they
had stopped um they there was like a a
little um shelter type thing that they
had built like for hikers and stuff that
had like a little it was kind of redim
let's call it that but it did have kind
of a little shitty looking cabin and
like might have had some fire wood and
[__] like that where you could get in
there and like get out of the weather so
I don't know if they just didn't know if
that was there or they were just like
[__] it we're too tired to walk that far
or cuz I think it was something like 2
kilometers away or something like that
so maybe they were just like [__] it
we're not we're just going to stop here
um some people have also speculated
maybe the map they had wasn't accurate
and it didn't have it on it or something
like that but nobody really knows but
for whatever reason they stopped and
camped out in this essentially like an
open field now despite the hardships
that they had had had this day like with
this horrible weather that was not in
any way expected um they did kind of
seem in good spirits regardless um you
know they kind of had some food and like
sat around it's like man we made really
good time and we're doing really good
and [__] like that they didn't seem like
super bummed out or anything cuz like I
said they were all experienced hikers
they had been through [__] like this
before so you know it wasn't that big of
a deal to them so they kind of managed
to fall asleep a little bit at 400 in
the morning um the wind which like I
said was really bad it actually SNA all
the tent ropes cuz I think they were all
in two uh tents that were like the
driest ones and it snapped the tent
ropes on one of the so they all had to
get wake up and like go fix that and
then when they all got back in the like
the wind tore out the stakes from the
other tent so you know so they didn't
really get much sleep is what I'm saying
because all of this [__] [__] was
going on and the weather was just
getting shittier and shittier and then
when they woke up the following morning
apparently everything was covered with
snow even though it's [__]
August so after after that we will
return to what happened to that party
afterward but let's Jump Ahead a little
bit so Natalia yod milla's daughter who
as I said was leading her own group and
they were supposed to meet up on August
5th so Natalia and her gang they get to
the meeting place on August 5th like
they're supposed to right on time but um
Natalia's mom and her group were not
there now Natalia later said that she
was not alarmed uh you know she's like
hey you know my mom is a master
survivalist and master hiker we've been
through [__] like this before it's like
I'm sure it's fine she's like the
weather was shitty so it probably just
slowed them down it's not that big of a
deal so her and the group just went on
ahead and said yeah we'll just meet up
like back at the base of the mountain or
whatever and everything will be fine
what they're doing ain't easy people who
who who've never been hiking um if I was
Infantry
and we do a very similar kind of thing
we're mostly hiking they that was airb
infantry they drop you off in a
helicopter and the rest of us you're
hiking I also hiked up in eity all right
Smoky Mountains
also the uh chances are they're carrying
at least 40 lbs worth of equipment and a
likely yeah and a 40 lb pack to a person
who's never carried a pack before and
you Tred to climb up [__] mountains
and walk around 10 15 maybe 20 miles a
day that will that will [__] smoke
your legs the next day you wouldn't be
able to walk I will note that I think
the hike they were on was maybe four or
five days planned and I think it was
like 140 miles or so it was a long way
that's pretty good it was a long way
yeah and they're carrying
packs I mean my [__] would get up to 110
pounds worth of equipment which is the
pack and I was carrying an M60 at the
time uh was Carri ammo snow gear [__]
uh what's called an ice bag that that
had all our [__] NBC or nuclear
biological and chemical suit was in that
four pair of [__] boots [__] tons of
[__] gloves then all that food and
then water water weighs a lot so they're
probably carrying a lot of weight
they're at least carrying 40 pounds a
piece I think it's probably safe that
they're carryed probably safe to say
that they started out with 60 60 to 80
pound they probably did for for a
several day heke right and then they as
they eat it gets lighter and as as they
drink it gets lighter and no you you
can't drink snow there's not if you were
to melt snow there's not enough water in
there to get a drink you take you know
if you have a big fire going you can
eventually get some water but you can't
just eat snow and oh yeah it's like
please don't do that no that's a bad
idea no if you a whole handful of snow
is really only a couple drops of
water when it melts so uh yeah they're
tired and usually you're not talking
you're silent and you're usually in
stagger Ranger file or a straight line
depending on what the terrain's like and
there's going to be a distance in
between each hiker it doesn't sound like
they're using lines to connect each
other in case somebody Falls that's more
mountaineering yeah these mountains were
not I mean they're high but they're not
I saw like um I saw them on Google Earth
and stuff they're not like super craggy
where you'd be like climbing up sheer
Rock faces or anything chances are
they're spaced out 10 m each 5 m
each there's usually never any
conversation going on it's just this
droning walk through the
Wilderness and your mind goes kind of
numb almost like what what Long Haul
truckers get with white line fever you
you you start to lose your [__] mind
especially if it's real cold or real hot
uh so that's just giving you guys some
background personal experience and a
background on what these hikers are
starting to experience by this time
they're starting to experience
fatigue
yeah and the thing about it is is that
it this part of the world in this time
of year which like I said it was summer
it was August so it wasn't cold cold up
there it wasn't hot either and the thing
about it is because yeah Jen said
typhoon maybe maybe that was the word I
was thinking I wasn't sure tyon is the
same as a hurricane though that's yeah I
know but I know that they had like a
different yeah yeah I just can't
remember I saw a documentary about it
and they used a word and I was like
maybe it was typhoon but I can't
remember what it was but um but yeah so
because of the and the winds it was like
actually much colder than they were
predicting but still not like top of
Mount Everest cold you know what I'm
saying so cold but not that cold and
just because it's cold doesn't mean that
they're not sweating to death You' sweat
and your socks would get [__] wet
with sweat and because it's cold then
they start to get really [__] chilly
and if you stop and don't change your
socks you can get frostbite cuz your the
the water in your socks will start
freezing up um so they're going through
all this but they're they got somebody
who's experienced with them they
probably tell them to change socks every
six hours yeah like I said they were all
as as young as some of them were they
had all been on Hikes before and they
were like I said this chick and zanada
said um she was known for helping young
men prepare for military training as
well this was a tough chick yeah she um
she knew her [__] and like I said she
was kind of like somebody that was very
well known in the area for being like
the best like hiking instructor the best
survivalist instructor and [__] like and
all of her students loved her I
recommend hiking if you're young you
want to learn skills you say well I
don't want to join the military but I
want those kind of skills one of the
things you should do is join a hiking
class it can be in any terrain desert
mountains whatever there's somebody out
there teaching it and they'll give you
the survival skills for that terrain and
you say well that's kind of that's
basically what the military does that's
what good [__] to know you know what I
mean it's good [__] to know yeah and
each each area has its own skill set you
know know like Rangers got to go [__]
swamp desert and a uh [__] swamp
desert and what's the other
one
jungle oh no no swamp is Jungle the
desert and I forgot the other one was
Forest I think I guess there was three
different three different ones you have
to do not like snow
mountains Snowy Mountains I don't think
it was snow cuz I feel like Snowy
Mountains you probably need to know that
too in case your plane crashes or some
[__] like that like those I know they
had a desert pH rugby players I know
they had a desert phase I know they had
a jungle
phase I didn't go to that though I just
I just remembered that they had those
too yeah but this one like I said it's
and whatever the terrain is obviously
you have to like be specific to that
terrain right this one like I said it
wasn't it wasn't like an expedition to
Everest type situation but it was a
similar you know it's going to be cold
snowy mountains you know is basically
what this is so and this was considered
like I said a pretty strenuous itinerary
for this
area so as I said so her daughter's team
shows up at the Meetup point and her
mom's team isn't there but like I said
she's not worried about it uh and she
said later yeah we weren't worried about
it you know it had happened before the
weather was bad they knew the weather
was bad in that area they're like oh
that probably just slowed him down no
biggie we'll just keep on going and meet
up with them later you know what I mean
okay August 10th 5 days
later there was a group of uh Ukrainian
kayakers on the river uh kind of at the
foot of the Kamar deban mountain range
and while they were going down the river
they see something kind of over on the
shore they see this one young woman kind
of standing and looking at
them um According to some versions of
the story which I think is maybe
exaggerated uh that she had dried blood
on her um other versions of the story
don't mention mention that and I think
that it probably wouldn't make much
sense because it was days later at this
point and she probably would have washed
herself in the river rather than having
dried blood on her for four or five days
so I I don't know if I believe that that
might be a later exaggeration but some
versions of the story say that so I
thought I would mention it now the
kayakers go up to her and say she also
had she either had like a white T-shirt
or a sleeping bag like hanging on the
tree like as a little bit of like a flag
you know what I mean so people would
notice it
so the kayakers I think they passed her
at first because she didn't call out to
them like for help or anything she just
kind of like looked at them and so they
were like okay so they kept on going but
then they thought you know that's pretty
weird maybe we should go back and like
see what's the matter so they went back
and asked what was going on and she just
immediately started crying and like
started to tell them some stuff but what
she was saying like sounded kind of you
know it was kind of broken up like they
couldn't really tell what she was
talking about now they eventually got
out of her
that this was Valentina udko the
17-year-old and she told them that she
had been in a group with six other
people but that they were all
dead so the kayakers at this point they
take her to the nearest police station
so she could file a
report now at first she was too
traumatized to really they couldn't
really get out of her like what exactly
had happened it took a few days for her
to like settle down and and once you
like hear what happened I'm sure you
will understand that like it took her a
while to like [__] sort out her [__]
you know what I mean um to tell them
like what exactly to for her to calm
down enough to tell them exactly what
had
happened so this is what she told
them she said that they got up that
morning like I said the morning after
the storm had like blown their tents
around and everything and they didn't
get much sleep and they woke up and
there was a bunch of snow and blahy blah
so they were only at 24 hours or was it
48 they were out they left on
um the second mhm and then the bad [__]
happened to them like over the night of
the fourth and the fifth okay so they've
been out there for three and four days
right okay yeah okay
so so they had they got up and it's like
they were they were kind of tired but
you know what I mean they were going to
like make some time today so they they
all ate breakfast together and then they
started descending the mountain like
following the itinerary like toward the
Meetup point with Natalia
about 20 minutes after they started the
Trek um Sasha the 23-year-old man
started screaming he was in the rear of
the
group everybody turned around to look at
him and noticed that he was frothing at
the mouth and there was blood coming out
of his eyes and his ears uh some say
it's nose as well uh pretty much after a
couple of seconds um he started
convulsing and collapsed to the ground
and then went still like pretty quickly
huh um sounds familiar go ahead uh leod
Milla who like I said was like a mom to
him freaked out obviously and ran back
like to see what was the matter with him
like picking it up and hugging him and
trying to like wake him back up like
what you know what happened what
happened um you know and they said she
was really upset
Valentina uh she goes up to leod Milla
and um leod Milla told her it's like I
can't hear a heart
beat um for whatever reason l Miller
says ask Valentina go get Victoria like
the other girl but Valentina goes over
to get Victoria Victoria bit
her okay um so Valentina is like what
the [__] girl like probably and then
kind of drags her back over to the
others like I don't know what the [__]
is going on right now this is
crazy so then probably like a minute or
two later leod Milla starts screaming
like screaming for help they all turn to
look at her and notice that she was also
frothing at the mouth and bleeding out
her eyes and ears and
nose so they all rushed over obviously
to help her cuz they're like holy [__]
what the [__] is going
on um and again again she started
convulsing and then fell on top of Sasha
these are kind of the symptoms so far I
know you said don't jump in before I
know everything but that sounds like
that sounds like the symptoms of what's
called with a certain kind of chemical
agent called U blood agent it's like a
nerve
agent the Soviets had it we knew that
they had it well that's one of the
theories so like I said don't jump ahead
because that's we're going to get into
that later okay yeah that's blood agent
[__] denatured your [__]
hemoglobin your blood turned into foam
and that's the his those are the
symptoms of
it that's the first thing I thought when
I the first time I read this well like I
said that is one of the theories so
we'll get into that it's like a nerve
agent but it's
different it could defeat the valves in
a mask that's one of we know the Ser it
would eat the valves have a bunch of The
Masks have a bunch of valves in them
they have to open so you can in in Hal
and when you exhale they seal up all
right well those valves are very thin
and one of the characteristics of blood
agent is that it would destroy those
Rubber and thin rubber it would eat it
out so the valves wouldn't work in your
mask and you'd breathing in no matter
what even if you had the mask on and and
that's how you died way they're
describing it not saying that's what it
is but I don't know where they got that
where they got blood agent it might be
biological I don't know which means
maybe you can find that in nature we'll
see we'll see yeah like I said we'll
we'll get into that cuz like I have big
long thing about one of the theories
that that involves
that so the next person that was
affected was
Tatiana uh she came over to leod Milla
to help her see what was going on and
pretty much as soon as she came over
there um Valentina said she started like
clutching at her throat like she
couldn't breathe and then she said she
crawled over to like a rock or a Boulder
nearby and started smashing her own head
against it yeah um until she lost
Consciousness well she's malfunctioning
yeah so God so like I said I can't
imagine like just seeing this happen in
front of you when everything was normal
five minutes ago that must been like
[__]
horrible now Dennis one of the other
guys he's like [__] this and he ran and
like hid behind a rock um and kind of
getting into a sleeping bag that was
back there um the other two Timar and
Victoria they kind of like took off
running Valentina basically was just
kind of standing there Frozen for a
second like what the [__] is actually
happening which is probably what I would
be doing also now Victoria and te and um
Timor who had both kind of run away but
while they were running they didn't get
very far they ran a little bit and then
they started tearing some of their
clothes off um kind of having blood
spewing out of their facial orifices
and kind of scratching at their throats
like I said like they couldn't breathe
or like their throat was closing up and
then they basically just fell to the
ground and stopped
moving at this point Valentina and
Dennis um realize well we're pretty much
the only two left standing right uh we
need to get the [__] out of here um so
they basically ran
away um sadly Dennis didn't make it very
far either either he ran a little way
and then collapsed um and started to
convulse just like the others had like
same
symptoms and at this point Valentina is
just kind of like she doesn't know
what's going on but she's like I need to
get away from here like right now
because obviously whatever it is is in
this area and I'm next you know what I
mean so she just [__] took off
running the only thing that she had on
her was the clothing she was wearing and
she had like a ENT that was it so she
just ran uh into the
woods and um basically she came to a
point where you know I don't know I
don't remember how far it was exactly
that she ran but she ran like until she
was like I think I'm far enough away now
and then she just set up her tent and
she was exhausted obviously so she just
like crashed and like fell asleep for a
little while now when she woke up
several hours later she uh made a very
depressing realization which is is all I
have is a tent and if I'm going to be
stuck out here in the wilderness by
myself I'm going to need food and gear
and [__] like that and I don't have any
so I'm going to have to go back to where
all the people are dead and where maybe
there's something that's killing them um
and go back and get it because I'm going
to die otherwise man that's risky yeah
but I mean she thought well I don't have
a choice like I'm going to die without
anything she didn't she didn't have any
food she didn't have any water she
didn't have anything days out she's four
days out anyway so she and she wasn't
entirely sure where she was like she
didn't have the map or anything like
that see to deliver any any kind of like
nerve agent or blood agent it's going to
be in two different forms it's going to
be p a persistent agent or a
non-persistent agent depending
on what it is the designers
wanted if it's non-persistent it's
usually some kind of a Ste uh Mist maybe
blow BL out of something like a crop
duster or out of an explosive shell or a
bomb or bomb lit that goes off at a
certain altitude it'll puff it out and
it'll come down and it'll rain down in
kind of like a
Mist but it's
non-persistent a few hours later you can
go through that area and it's safe
because it's neutralized
itself you can adjust it another way to
make it persistent you spray it down on
on on things like foliage or roads and
you and it stays there you can they can
they have fixing agents usually it's
like some kind of
oil and it might stay good for weeks or
months and it's kind of like a portable
mine field but it's a you a mine field
that's been it's semi invisible and it's
been deployed by an aircraft or shells
artillery
shells it looks good you walk through it
you pick that stuff up it gets on your
you know it's all on the branches and
the branches are hitting you or they're
hitting your pant leg leg and over time
it the pant leg then rubs up against
your skin and it transfers into your
skin and it's just contact alone you
have to breathe it um just enough
contact you'll absorb through your skin
and it'll set off that damn Chain
Reaction especially if it's a nerve
agent you know and that's really made
out of cter beans really easy to make if
you know what you're doing there a there
was a a Japanese terrorist religious
terrorist made a bunch of it and let it
Let It Go in the [__]
Tokyo Subway kill a bunch of people but
they didn't really quite deliver it
right they they you know they it was the
first time they'd ever done it um we
never did show on that did we yeah it
killed a bunch of people but they could
have killed a lot more had they done it
right had they not deliver it so what it
sounds like and just going off the top
of my head it sounds like somebody used
some kind of blood agent and it was pers
it was a persistent form of it which
left it on the ground kind of like a an
invisible mindfield usually it's like a
little bit of oily looking or maybe like
dro
or just a [__] shiny film and and
they walk through it the other one's got
enough on them to kill them or some
reason this girl she either didn't walk
through it
or she only got a little bit of it on
her or maybe it just on the bottom of
her shoes and then she walked it off and
she was never contaminated but if she
goes back into that
area to get supplies off those bodies if
it is some kind of persistent agent
she'd be lucky to survive it because
those bodies are going to be and their
clothing is going to be contaminated
with that
stuff but she made it back so yeah she
still alive as far as I know it sounds
like a sophisticated nerve agent called
blood agent which is not quite a nerve
agent but it's what it sounds like well
like I said we'll get into that more
like when I get into the theory section
because we're still kind of in this like
I said um yeah Zan said imagine how
horrified you'd be I can't imagine like
what this [__] girl went through
seriously
um and Z said the fact that Valentina
survived 3 days or whatever I think it
was four days actually by herself in the
wilderness is a feed on its own yeah big
time so yeah so she makes the horrible
decision I'm going to have to go back
and get some stuff you know what I mean
because I'm not going to survive out
here by myself because I'm not sure
where I'm
at um so she did it she went back up um
to where that they had all died now she
saw that all of the people there I mean
she checked obviously to make sure that
they were not alive anymore and they
weren't um and basically she's like
everyone was in the exact same position
they had been when they had fallen so
they must have like died like
immediately you know what I mean like
they didn't it was fast acting yeah cuz
she's like they were all still in the
same position like that she remembered
them you said they were foaming at the
mouth a pink foam well I don't know okay
usually pink foam they just said foaming
at the mouth and then you know blood
coming out of the tear Ducks sometimes
and out of the mucus membranes the
nose okay but you said that some of them
were doing that right right mhm blood
right yeah okay yeah bleeding from the
ears eyes nose blood agent denatures the
hemoglobin in your cells it R ruptures
the [__] cell wall so your blood just
turns into foam and your blood pressure
kind of goes up but your heart really
can't beat it because it's just foam
it's not liquid and because it's gotten
bigger a bunch of [__] bubbles in it
gas bubbles I guess you start foaming at
the mouth and you start bleeding out of
weird orifices you can't breathe then
you die by suffocation basically thank
you Janet that's really nice of you
thanks Janet thank you very much appr I
love the little cartoon there yeah
because you're your blood's just become
foam you can't your heart can't can't be
can't pump it and uh there's no red
blood cells in there anymore anyway
they're all torn up it's probably a bad
way to go
Suffocation I mean it looks like a
pretty bad way to go at least it was
quick it seemed like but it looked like
it was like super painful though yeah
well you would start glitching out your
brain and start glitching out you go
into convulsions like you said thrashing
around beating your head against rocks
and stuff well like I said one of the
other girls bit her as well like B her
yeah kind kind of like a rabies type
reaction yeah and some people have
wondered if maybe this was rabies too
but I don't think it's rabies because it
takes a long time in your to uh incubate
yeah and this was like seemed like it
was immediate this was some kind of
sabotage or military accident that's
what I'm thinking right now okay go
ahead well thank you
um yeah just so so yeah so she comes
back she gets what she needs to get
checks and make sure obviously they're
all dead and they just died where they
fell evidently because none of them are
in a different position like I said some
of them had pulled off some of their
clothes I think two or three of them
were Barefoot like it had taken their
shoes off too which you know before they
died yeah well I'm not yeah they they
started like ripping their clothes off
and stuff so that's why some people we
get into that in a minute yeah but um
but yeah so at this point she sees like
a thing um like they have power lines on
it and she's like okay well I'm just
going to follow the power lines because
that will probably lead back to
civilization right so she follows the
power lines down the mountain for like
four
days now unfortunately for her the power
lines did lead to a village but the
village was completely abandoned and
there was nothing in it that she could
use um but luckily for her like right
behind this abandoned Village she saw a
river and she's like oh well obviously
all the tourists are going to be in the
area everybody's going to be kayaking
down that River so I'm going to go down
there and follow the river until I find
somebody and again like she wasn't down
there that long before the kayakers came
along and found her so she was rescued
um interestingly they said that she
couldn't tell them at first like what
had happened she really only started
talking after they had picked her up and
then they were in the kayak like taking
her back to civilization and she passed
another group on of kayakers and she
recognized them as somebody that she'd
met like on the train like on the way to
the place like to the way to the trail
head and then she started talking cuz I
guess that kind of like oriented her or
something like that but yes they said
she started talking then and really her
account of this she wrote like a really
long account of it for the police um and
then didn't talk about it again
afterward for many years and who can
[__] blame her really but um she um I
that's really the only account that we
have of like what happened up there you
know what I
mean so she gave the police a report
like I said it took them a while to get
it out of her but she did give them a
very detailed report of what exactly had
happened however um no formal search for
the other six hikers was undertaken
until August 2th 4 which was almost 2
weeks later why which that kind of
fueled a lot of suspicions and
conspiracy theories later on yeah now I
will note that according to some sources
they said the weather was too shitty to
like go out there like sooner but then I
saw some other sources that said no the
weather was fine and there were other
maybe more nefarious reasons why they
didn't go out there cover you know what
I mean yeah well you know yeah um now I
also saw some sources that said that
there were a couple of other hikers
whose names were Ivon vasnev and Olga
indova that they also went missing
around the same time in the same area
because of the weather but um you know
half happily they were all found they
were both found alive and were
rescued so finally Valentina kind of
told them where to look um but I guess
she wasn't like real articulate or
whatever because they went out there
with helicopters finally like two weeks
later and it took them like 2 days of
flying around in the helicopters before
they found the bodies even though they
were in like an open area they weren't
like in the trees or anything like that
they were out in a big open field
there's cuz like I said there's pictures
of it they're kind of gross but if you
want to look at them you can um when
they found the bodies obviously it had
been a while uh so they were very
swollen and had been partially eaten by
animals and eaten by insects and you
know their eyes were gone and [__] like
that so I'm sure that was like real a
real nice day
now according to the medical
examiner five of the hikers had died of
hypothermia um leod Milla they said had
died of a heart
attack H I don't know that sounds very
very fishy to me sounds like a [__]
um according to the autopsy they also
all had bruised lungs and they all had
protein deficiency as though they had
been
starving which again seems very
odd um so they said that it was this
protein deficiency and I hypothermia
that had brought on the death all at
once no so well yeah we'll get into that
so so you know the deaths were ruled
accidental which I don't disagree with
that necessarily but I don't think the
cause of death is correct at all he lied
so yeah so AC I mean according to what
Valentina said happened to them I'm like
hypothermia I don't think so I mean
maybe technically I don't know we'll get
into it in a minute hypothermia could
have technically been the cause of death
but I don't think that was like the
other one died of a heart attack yeah I
don't think and then they were no it
wouldn't all happen within a first in
the same spot that's what I mean I don't
think right at the same time I mean this
all happened according to Valentina this
happened like within minutes yeah like
almost simultaneously well the this this
the the crime scene if that's you want
to call it they were all right there
they were all like really close like I
said I saw the photos they're all like
right there and she said they died where
they fell what the autop autopsy is
suggesting is that they died one by one
by different means which meant they
would have died over a period of a few
days they'd be strung out over that
trail yeah no they died all at once from
the same thing yeah that's what that's
what I think too yeah that's what I
think too so as you imagine uh a case
this [__] weird there's all kind of
theories about what happened to these
poor people um you know that range from
pretty scientifically plausible uh you
know at least from my point of view to
crazy [__] because obviously just like
in the diav pass incident people are
going to say it was aliens or it was a
Yeti or something like that which is
[__] we're not even going to talk
about that um because I I suspect I kind
of know what what maybe happened here so
let's talk about some of the possib
abilities now some of these are not
mutually exclusive like some of these
could work in tandem with one another
that's for sure but let's kind of get
into that before we get any further now
the first one that we have to um address
is possibly maybe valentina's story was
not accurate um you know I I don't
believe that that's true I believe she
saw what she said she saw but you do
have to take that into account maybe she
misremembered it or maybe she
exaggerated it because of trauma or
whatever you know what I mean there's
lots of different CU you know people's
memories aren't super accurate and all
that kind of stuff all those bodies are
right there but yeah so but I but I said
you do kind of have to take that into
account because she's the only person
that was there that saw it happen so
some people said well you know it's
we're not saying that I you know I don't
believe this is the case I believe that
she told it accurately because her story
hasn't changed over the years she told
it back then and she told it again like
I believe in 2019 and it hasn't changed
in all that time um so I just don't
really think that she made it up or
embellished it or anything like that I
believe she saw what she said she saw
you know the scene supports her case
yeah that too um but like I said it's
you know it's something that you do have
to take into consideration murdered
there was no blun Force
Dr nothing like that like that so she
didn't kill him to make up a
story I did see that one this doesn't
necessarily mean that she didn't see
what she said she saw but I did see one
user on Reddit because there was like a
big Reddit Thread about this with people
kind of throwing out their own
hypothesis and I thought this was kind
of I don't know if I don't think this is
the case either but I did think this was
interesting and maybe was a possibility
so one Reddit user said that maybe
Valentina the reason why she survived
when everyone else died maybe she wasn't
even there when the deaths happened like
maybe she went ahead by herself um just
because because she thought the others
were too slow or because she had argued
with them or something you know what I
mean or go ahead and get something like
somebody told her to go ahead and get
something or something like that um and
then like she kind of was just waiting
for them to catch up and they didn't and
then she's like well [__] it and she
just set up a tent and fell asleep and
then the next morning when they weren't
there she went back and found them all
dead and then maybe she kind of like
made up the account as the as a way of
kind of like rationalizing or explaining
what had happened to them you know what
I mean which like I said I don't I don't
believe that's true but I just found
that and I thought that was kind of
interesting because it would explain
like why she didn't fall victim to
whatever the other six fell victim to
cuz a lot of people are like Why didn't
it kill her too whatever it was that
Happ she just would have told that
version of the story yeah you would
think cuz it yeah it wouldn't have
really there would be really be no
motivation for her went back to go see
what happened to them and yeah and in
some ways that would have been even like
cuz she'd have been like hey I just
thought they were right behind me and
then like I went back and they were all
dead I don't know what the [__] happened
you know what I mean it would have been
like that right so I don't know why she
would have any motivation to like not
tell that story if that had been what
happen like I said I believe her um I
think that it happened pretty much
exactly like she said so I'm but I just
thought that I would throw that out
there so the second theory that people
had put forward that maybe indeed they
did die of hypothermia or exposure just
like the um the autopsy said yeah now um
the thing about it so even though the
weather was much colder than
predicted I will note that all of the
hikers had colder weather gear clothing
in a plastic bag like in their pack so
they didn't suit up so they didn't suit
up so it obviously wasn't cold enough
for them to bust out the Colder Weather
yeah gear which they would have done if
it now Valentina did say it got really
cold because of the rain and everything
like that but apparently it wasn't cold
enough for them to bust out like the big
guns you know what I mean like the
colder weather gear so I will note that
yeah another thing doesn't doesn't check
out if they're all basically wearing the
same
rig and and and they all die of [__]
hypothermia when she's with the party
but she doesn't die even though she's
wearing the same clothes and she she
would have never survived it she would
have died along with them no she
survived another couple days walking
back four days four days she survived
another four days no her story checks
out and the thing about it is like she
was very physically fit but I don't
think she was any more physically fit
than anyone else on the track Co doesn't
really kind of care how physically fit
you are right and the yeah so so I don't
think that that really would made you're
overweight you'll actually last longer
because you're more insulated yeah so no
she so eat that
candy no it wasn't the cold it would
have taken her down too see I kind of
think that too I think the only reason
that some people throw that out out
there is because of the paradoxical
undressing because she did say that some
of them had started tearing their
clothes off but and that is a thing that
happens like with
hypothermia um and that might have been
uh something that happened in the de la
of pass incident also although I think
in that case I think they were probably
sleeping in their tent with not that
many clothes on and then they just
panicked and ran out without getting
dressed symptoms of nerve agent runny
nose difficulty swallowing [__]
confusion those are the [__] that's
the [__] Main yeah so like I said
this might have been not hypothermia
this might have been something else that
AFF their thought processes it's either
nerve agent or [__] blood agent which
I think they may be one of the same the
blood agent was an improved one I didn't
really haven't really researched blood
agent they probably wouldn't tell us
exactly what that was anyway you guys
may be able to Google well like I said
we'll get into it in a little bit
because I have some notes about that
kind of stuff no it may have been nerve
agent or blood agent because no that
that fits that [__] hits you and you
start acting [__] crazy do all kinds
of crazy which like I said that would
that would explain um biting people
biting people and the and the and the
girl smashing her head against The Rock
confused speech that kind of [__]
confused thinking slurred speech yeah
that's nerve agent or blood agent I will
note too that I don't believe the
hypothermia thing because it wouldn't
have killed all of them in such a short
period of time no I mean hypothermia
would take you like there'd be like a
longer period of time because depending
on the person's physiology and well if
they're all in the same gear or Bas
roughly the same gear they would all die
at the same time more or
less you know what I mean but within
like minutes of each other that seems I
don't yeah you you would die within
minutes if you're sitting there with a
huge blast 100 below zero you doesn't
matter what you're but like I said this
it wasn't that cold that cold yeah then
they weren't in
gear then they didn't die of that
because you have to think the weather
had been shitty for a day or two it
wasn't like it just came out of nowhere
so if it was really that cold like the
day before or something like that they
would have busted out the Colder Weather
I've been out 20 below I've been out 20
below zero
fahrenheit doing military operations but
you're wearing gear yeah you your feet
are [__] cold but it's not killing
you you know it didn't get down to 20
below Fahrenheit did it yeah then no not
close not even close regular regular
cold weather gear would would like I
said it was summer it was summer yeah it
was August yeah that's not hypothermia
it doesn't now James knap makes the
point and I thought of this too and I
think I have this in my notes but he
said the nerve agent could have knocked
them unconscious and they didn't wake up
from the coma and then they died of
hypothermia that's a possibility or
exposure the thing is those nerve agents
[__] extremely toxic once it's in you
you're going to die yeah you don't
[__] get I'm just saying that that's
a possibility too like maybe that's and
it maybe red is hypothermia but nerve
agent is bug spray for humans all right
it makes you very very sick bug spray is
a similar thing it's just that it
attacks only their systems not ours
um no uh one drop of it on a needle will
kill you you know it might take a little
bit longer but it'll kill you and you
really can't recover the atropine
injection kit which is like a whole
bunch of valume and a whole bunch of
adrenaline can keep you alive for a
little bit
longer they might be able to do
something like a blood transfusion on
you but you're going to be [__] up
you're never going to be a s again I I
saw some training films a long time ago
at the NBC school this is back in the
80s that he went there of Contra Rebels
that had been hit with Soviet VX gas and
they have like two sets of atropine
injector kits in their [__] Pockets
where they've been giving themselves and
they're drooling and one eye bigger than
the other and SF guys filming them they
were walking crooked and they were doing
you know like hold your arm up you'd be
like that they all died though the
atropine kept them alive for a little
bit longer but they all died when it
once it's in you it kills you it's only
a matter of
time that atropine is not an not an
antidote not really more like a placebo
makes you feel better keep you keep you
running for a little bit longer May
they're hoping that maybe you'll be able
to flush it out through your kidneys or
something
no I've never really heard of anybody
ever come in contact with it
surviving but then again not a lot of
people come in contact with it I did
hear a story and I was going to save
this for the nerve gas portion but um I
did hear a story about a Russian
scientist who's working on this
particular nerve gas I can't remember
what his name was but um he supposedly
there was an accident in the lab and he
was exposed to it he lived but he was um
never the same no like I think he was
like he had to be in a wheelchair and he
brain damaged and stuff like that yeah
so you know what I mean yeah and it was
probably just a very small minute amount
too it's all it takes yeah I think it's
just like the the thing in the um the
test tube like busted or something if
it's good gas or good VX it's invisible
it's odorless it's tasteless you even
know you've been dosed you don't know
how badly you've been dosed if it's
you've been hit full blast with it
you're going to die there no way around
it well probably like immediately yeah
in seconds that's why like I said when I
first started reading about this like
the symptoms and stuff I said that
sounds like some nerve agent right there
like I thought that same thing and I
still kind of think that but we'll get
into in a second cuz I'm going through
the list of
theories uh some people have also
proposed altitude sickness and I don't
really buy this one either now I will
admit that altitude sickness can account
for some of the symptoms like confusion
hallucinations um you know vomiting
things like that um you know just
suddenly acting real crazy um and this
also maybe uh might explain if this was
like a longer term thing maybe that was
why they camped in the weird spot that
they camped cuz they weren't really
thinking right or something like that
like some people have put that forward
because it's like you know the tree line
was not that far like why didn't you
camp under there because the weather was
so shitty instead of out in the open you
know what I mean um on the other hand I
will note that where they were staying
wasn't really that high it was less than
8,000
ft um and they were actually like
descending at the time of their death
they weren't ascending
um and I'm going to say too altitude
sickness generally comes on kind of
slowly I mean depending on the person
and it's really never you never see um
severe symptoms like that at these
altitudes um that would cause you know
the extreme [__] that we see here I have
had altitude sickness one time uh the
first time I went to
Denver and you know cuz that's Mile High
and then we went up in the mountains and
that then the mountain that we went up
to was actually higher than this it was
11,000 ft I think 10,000 11,000 ft it
didn't bother me when I was up there but
then like later on I started feeling
like really and really all I felt was
like really I had a headache and I felt
like really really nauseated you know
what I mean and it lasted probably like
a day but nothing like this now I know
that it like at extreme altitudes yeah
you can have all kind of like extreme
symptoms but I don't I just don't think
this was high enough for for the
symptoms to have been this extreme now
it could be that they had some mild
sickness and it was causing confusion
and stuff like that which may be led to
some other things but I just don't think
that's the case I'm just saying that
that's might have been a factor but I
doubt it that's all I'm saying so now
we're getting into the
more uh I want to say like conspiracy
theory [__] but you know what I mean
like some of the stuff that was maybe
more on
purpose you know so one of the theories
is that maybe
they stumbled across uh something they
weren't supposed to now according to
this
hypothesis um maybe the hikers came
across some secret Russian military
experiment going on in the mountains and
were killed because they saw something
they shouldn't have uh it's the same
kind of thing that people say about the
diov hikers yeah I don't really believe
it here either well here's the thing um
I believe there might have been a mild
cover up as James naap said yeah nerve
gas with mild government cover up I
think that's kind of where I'm going
with this too um because I do think
there was a mild cover up because I
think they said oh they died of
hypothermia and a heart attack and I
don't buy that not for one second um was
there was there a test range anywhere
near this area well we'll get into that
in a second um so yeah so I do think
that the medical examiner did maybe lie
or was told to lie about the cause of
death now according to Natalia Le
milla's daughter um her and the other
family members of the other victims were
not allowed to see the bodies I don't
know if that's the case but that's what
she said anyway probably not allowed to
they were they were rotten anyway yeah
they didn't look too good um from from
the photos that I saw and from you know
all all accounts see here actually they
said that even like hardened
[__] that went up there like
threw up when they saw the [__] so it
was pretty bad um now you know but some
people that are proponents of this
Theory say that it's like well they took
a different route than usual and it's
possible that they could have stumbled
across some you know something going on
that they shouldn't have seen and then
they got like killed [__] but here's
the
thing um there's kind of two things that
speak against this
Theory uh one as I mentioned earlier the
Kamar deband mountains this area in the
summer time is like a tourist hot spot
so it's really crowded you know what I
mean it's not crowded crowded there's
not wall toall people but there's a lot
of hiker groups and kayakers and stuff
like that there's just people everywhere
you know what I mean um if you were
going to do some top secret [__] in the
Kamar deband mountains which they do um
you know no one's denying that there is
some top top secret [__] going on out
there but you can go a 100 miles in one
direction and it's like super remote why
would you do something in the area where
all the tourists are that's dumb you
know what I mean because people will see
you so that seems really stupid also
they're like if that had indeed been the
case how did Valentina survive you know
what I mean like they would have killed
her too so why how did she get away no
it wasn't on purpose
that's yeah well that's kind of where
I'm going with it too so I'm just saying
that you know the way that where the um
the hikers died was like I said it was
an open field I mean you like I said if
you can see from the pictures it's open
you could see it from a a plane or a
helicopter you could see it from the
higher peaks of the mountain like it was
just all in the open there's no trees or
nothing um so it just seems like that
would be a dumb place to be doing top
secret government experiments you know
what I mean like like I said I'm not
saying that they don't do tests out
there because they do but not in that
area because it's really crowded
especially in the summertime um and
especially this summer because like I
said there was a big tourist Festival
going on so there's that now we're
getting into what I think is the most
likely scenario there's some other ones
that we'll talk about later that are
maybe likely but this one uh nerve agent
yeah now the nerve agent that usually
gets brought up in regard to this case
is uh well VX is mentioned but it's
usually um Nova Nova okay
one
so now as we have mentioned is not VX
it's different no those are two
different things it's two different
things I don't know that one Nova yeah
or Nava chuk I'm not really sure how you
pronounce it right but um but yeah as we
have pointed out um foaming from the
mouth bleeding from the eyes convulsion
um that's a
pretty uh obvious those are pretty
obvious symptoms of nerve toxin you know
um also lung bruising which they did
find in the
autopsies um that is also kind of a
common uh symptom of some nerve gases
also because nerve gases will usually
cause like respiratory difficulty little
whisp of it right yeah and it can also
cause cardiac arrest which might have
explained why L milla's um cause of
death was cardiac arrest so that could
have been that the blood would have been
[__] poisoned though too although
maybe they didn't have a means to test
for it see I yeah I'm not sure if they
just like covered it up or if they
didn't actually test for that probably
uh covered it up probably told like man
it's preliminary [__] tell them this and
that they probably had some kind of a
KGB Med medical doctor was there and
told the other guy no this is what this
is what you're gonna say on the [__]
you know they probably looked at the
body together this is what you're going
to tell them on the on the octop prob
we're not going to mention any any nerve
agent poisoning that's what it was
though if you ask me the symptoms are
all right there yeah like I said that's
what I thought too yeah James says these
were super experienced hikers no [__]
way this was altitude sickness yeah I
didn't think that either like I said
they had been on like tons of hikes
before and this wasn't even a super high
mountain so that I'm sure it wasn't that
and like I said the worst youve I've
been higher than that and got altitude
sickness and all I did was like be real
nauseated like for a day you know what I
mean yeah that was about it so you have
to go up real high to get like extreme
altitude sickness like that so yeah um
so Navajo Gas uh was developed by uh
it's a family of nerve agents that was
developed by the Soviet Union I believe
they said that they stopped working on
it in 1993 which is the same year that
this incident
happened um what makes it navach is
supposedly yeah 10 times more lethal
than VX okay 20 times more lethal than
sarin okay um supposedly one of the
deadliest nerve agents ever conceived
maybe that's the one they're that they
told us was blood agent maybe that was
the name they told us maybe remember I
said it might might be blood agent
yeah probably just didn't tell us it was
novachuk they would have they would have
given it an American term to tell the
military that's probably what we knew as
blood agent because it was more
dangerous than VX yeah they might this
might have been what they were talking
about then probably what they were
talking about because I don't know I'm
not really sure
if you know uh information about this
particular nerve agent I don't think
came out until much later so well
everything was secret that's what I mean
all that [__] we had that [__] but it
was all secret they wouldn't talk about
about that because we had signed all we
had made other people sign all kinds of
agreements not to have [__] chemical
and biological weapons so we did it in
secret yeah we made them agree not to
have it but we did we were doing it well
they probably did the same thing they
did the same thing too they're like oh
yeah we're totally not going to do their
fingers across behind their back all all
this International rules of warfare is
the international rules of warfare are
whatever the United States tells you
they are that's what we tell all our
vassel and [__] this is what you have
and then people that we could bully this
is what you can and cannot have then we
did whatever the [__] we wanted and then
if the Soviet we couldn't control them
they had all kinds of [__] you know so
we would just pretend to follow rules we
didn't though [__] no we had all that
all that [__] was [__] put away
though and most of the chemical and
biological type agents they're not shelf
stable so they have to be broken down
into shelf stable components then
they're mixed and loaded into some kind
of weapon systems and then
delivered but the way the US Army did
things and the kind of people we were
fighting we didn't need biological
weapons or chemical weapons we just use
conventional [__] because America made
its bread and butter beating up on
little countries like Iraq [__] like
that Iraq and Afghanistan and [__]
Panama and [__] the Granada well it's
easier to look like a winner when you
pick on little I mean bullies know all
about that right it was that was that
was how the US empire grew they were
doing that in Central America and the
1800s and South America and [__] hey you
know we just got to face facts and you
know just got to face the facts I mean
you
know I was in that Army it was worse
than what we thought it
was you know nowadays everything you
can't hide anything because the internet
so you kind of see the game that they're
playing but uh yeah International rules
of War didn't really exist that was just
what we' tell other people to do hey
poke she's complaining Zan said the
documentary I saw said that um leod
milla's daughter admitted to receiving
government payouts oh I didn't see that
documentary I watched a bunch of
documentaries about it but I must not
have seen that money but maybe the one
that I saw I did see one that said that
she said that she wasn't allowed to see
the bodies yeah like see your mom's body
and stuff like that but I didn't see
when where she gotten payouts so yeah I
do kind of feel like there is like an
element of cover up to this but here's
the thing so um I probably need another
drink are were there any other is that
the last one no no no I I still got more
stuff to talk about I still got more
stuff to talk about um yeah James said
uh it's Russia KGB told them don't test
the blood and that's all it needs to be
done yeah I kind of figured that that's
probably what happened you know what I
mean um here's the thing though if it
was a nerve agent which I think it was
that's kind of the theory that I'm going
with I have a couple more to talk about
but this is is kind of the one that I
favor because it just seems
more it seems to fit all the symptoms
better um although I will note that it
is weird that Valentina wasn't affected
she didn't seem to be affected at all
even though she was right there like in
the same area and she even went back to
the area like afterward which like Tom
was saying was probably not a great idea
but like I said she didn't know what
else to do because she didn't have any
stuff so so some people have like used
that as an art arent against the nerve
gas thing because it's like well how
would Valentina have survived she would
have died like everyone else and the
thing about it too is that I think
there's kind of two different theories
as far as nerve gas goes because I think
people are talking about well nerve gas
as in someone was there to administer it
um I don't think that was the case
because I think you run into the same
problems that you run into with the
earlier theory that we talked about
where you know oh they saw something
they shouldn't have it's like why would
they be in this like super crowded area
I will note though that as far as I know
like according to reports they had
tested Nava in that mountain range not
you know like not then they weren't
doing it right then but they had done it
before so it wasn't so it's not crazy to
like think that so do I think somebody
sprayed them with nerve gas deliberately
like as a test no I don't think that
however
I think what happened was that they had
tested it there in the past and somehow
it still lingered around because here's
the
thing uh from everything that I read
about this particular nerve
agent um it can linger in the area for a
very long time after it's persistent
right after it's
deployed so it could have just hung
around in the atmosphere it could have
hung around in the trees in the water it
could have just been there um and I
believe that this nerve agent in
particular is water
soluble um and that it can take like a
really long time to dissipate like I
said so it can just kind of like hover
around in in the environment you know
what I mean and kind of just be
around now so it could
be that the that the Russian military
had been experimenting with this nerve
gas in this mountain range somewhere
like it probably wasn't in the super
tourist area cuz like I said that would
be real stupid but maybe somewhere else
in the area like not that far away maybe
months before or
whatever and it so happened that when
this hiking team was in this particular
area like I said there was a really bad
and unexpected storm with a lot of rain
that they weren't
expecting so it could be
that all of this rain that they had
maybe kind of like washed it whatever
was still lingering around farther up
the mountain kind of like washed it down
to where they were you know what I mean
so I think maybe the weather might have
had a factor might have uh played a
factor as well more likely that was
something like it was up in tree
limbs B and it rained which and it
washed it out of the trees and it was
landed on them landed on some of them
maybe something like that that's kind of
what I'm thinking that because I kind of
feel like I don't think anyone sprayed
them with it on purpose no I think that
it had been tested in another part of
those mountains earlier at some earlier
time and it was still like hanging
around in the envirment and then because
the weather was bad particularly with
all the rain and stuff like that it
maybe like washed it down to the area
where they were in it might have put it
into the groundwater it might have like
you know so it might have been hanging
around near the ground or whatever and
it just so happened that they wandered
across like a pocket of it you know what
I'm saying could have been
anything maybe they were maybe they had
an aircraft like a helicopter or an
airplane that was set up for like what
you would call crop dusting but it had
that stuff in it and they accidentally
discharged some of it at a high altitude
they got caught up in a wind and it blew
a small little puff of it blew and it
just happened to hit those kids hit some
of them and might have just been a real
weak dose of them yeah it didn't affect
anybody there were other hiking groups
in the same area and it didn't affect
anybody else could have been like maybe
they had it loaded up in some kind of
cluster munition or something and uh
they launched it they dropped this
[__] cluster bomb full of [__]
super VX and maybe one of the little
bomblets didn't deploy properly and when
the plane flew off the range to go back
that little little bombet it's like the
size of a fck just a little bomblet went
off it wasn't intended for them at all
this is some kind of an accident it said
I disconnected yeah I don't know if it
really did yeah it looks like it did
okay I don't know what that was about
the back okay just it says reconnected
it never went the the light is still
green it never changed color so I don't
it was some kind of they lost they lost
uh control over some nerve eding somehow
yeah I'm kind of thinking that that kind
of like is the closest to the symptoms
that she described yeah and the thing
about it it is weird that she lived
especially because what okay so what
they think in this scenario what they
think happened the first one to die was
Sasha the 23y old
man um he must have stumbled across a
pocket of it first and then um leod
Milla when she ran back to help him got
into the same pocket you know what I
mean because it seemed like they died in
the order that they went back to that
area you know what I'm saying the weird
thing about it though is that Valentin
went and touched I think L milla's arm
and but she didn't really seem to have
any effects so a lot of people I think
that's kind of the main thing that
people used to argue against the nerve
gas thing it's like well that would have
killed Valentina too Why didn't it
because like I said she was in the same
area and she went back to the area
afterward too like to get supplies like
the next morning I can tell you
why maybe it was waterborne some of it
was coming down a stream well I'll get
into that that's another one of my
theories like farther and they refilled
cantens there and were drinking it but
she didn't refill her canteen she had
enough water maybe something like
that yeah cuz some of these filled after
later and then it had it had blown by
already down the stream right cuz I
definitely think this was like a an
accidental deployment and it was like
just a pocket because there were other
people in the area and nobody else was
seemingly affected by this at all the
easiest way to kill a person like that
with with
nerve and then not affect anybody else's
to get to ingest it so they may have
ingested it accidentally but she
didn't so they drank it
maybe well I was going to get into that
cuz that was like a later thing too yeah
but yeah so it does seem like maybe the
poison was kind of like hanging out near
the ground because it does seem like
people that squatted down or something
like that like that they got it quicker
you know what I mean or that were in the
same area you think that that they
wouldn't even if they drank it they
wouldn't all die at exactly the same
time CU they wouldn't be drinking at the
same
rate yeah I think it's more likely that
it was Airborne yeah it came down and
hit him but it didn't hit
her or she wasn't somehow in the pocket
like she was just lucky to not it was
just like a whsp of smoke you know how
you have a cloud of cigarette smoking
and you see that that cloud Blow Away In
The Wind well a lot of those agents are
kind of basically laced with kind of oil
particles to keep them to to keep them
from going on the ground you're trying
to keep them Airborne you know so it
spreads and it might have come down in a
big wisp might have come from a very
high altitude in a big Wisp and it came
down got five of them but not the six of
six and then it blew past them and hit
the ground hit the trees and she didn't
never get any there wasn't enough of it
on her or they breathed it in it was
real weak you had to breathe you had to
ingest by inhaling it yeah maybe cuz I
think some of the nerve gas you can like
get it through the skin too all of them
but all of them all of them all you need
is a droplet if you were to take a
needle and dip it into VX which is
[__] very deadly and this is worse
than that if this is the one they're
talking about you can take a single
needle and dip it into liquid vs VX so
there's a little drop on it and you
could drop that droplet on the back of
your hand and you'll be dead in about 20
minutes which is really scary to think
about yeah and it's coming down in a m
yeah if it's full blast it's you know
you're being according to her this
happened like within minutes yeah Sasha
went down L Milla went down like minutes
later like not even a minute later it
seemed like the way she described it and
then the other ones like came over there
to help and then they started dropping
you know what I mean so it was like
immediate yeah which to me just seemed
that just sounds like nerve gas to me
yeah it's what it is um and also
remember how I said earlier that you
know they didn't even go out to look at
the body look for the bodies until like
almost two weeks later kind like they
knew and it's like yeah they they might
have so that's what fuels this theory is
just kind of like they're like well
maybe they suspected that it was some
nerve gas and they're like oh [__] maybe
we should wait a little while until that
all clears out of there and then we'll
go and check cuz they're probably dead
anyway Che out oh no they're dead going
to be dead yeah so they probably came up
with some [__] so oh the weather's
too bad or some other kind of crap
they're like well what's the half like
half like half they were probably
waiting for it all to clear out of the
area and then they were going to go the
half life I mean that makes total sense
yeah that's probably what it was cuz
they would ask well what's the half life
on the [__] and they said A week so that
means it take a week it's at half
strength two weeks it's safe right so
they waited about two weeks right it's
probably what they because I think they
found her on the 10th and then it took
and then I think they didn't go out
searching until the
24th so yeah so that's more than two
weeks actually yeah yeah they wanted to
make sure it was good and safe
yeah so that makes a lot of sense to me
now by the same token it's possible that
the nerve gas maybe wasn't like an onp
purpose nerve gas but was maybe
something naturally occurring yeah
that's possible too um like sulfur
Mercury something like that some kind of
weird spores maybe yeah that was maybe
released from underground or something
like that weird mold spores yeah it
could have been that have [__]
something like a neurotoxin and it maybe
yeah cuz that does exist yeah like in
nature so it could be that they just
were unlucky enough to stumble across
some pocket of something or other that
like came out of the ground or like you
said some kind of spores or something
like that um somebody on Reddit also
brought up I had never heard of this but
they were talking about this they said
that there are wolf and bear traps that
use springloaded
cyanide um that kills big animals and C
cyanide like sodium cyanide um does
cause similar symptoms convulsing
foaming at the mouth things like that um
they said the person also turns blue
which maybe could be mistaken for
hypothermia um and then if somebody
tried to give CPR to the person then
they would also ingest it so they said
that's another thing that maybe somebody
was poaching out there and like maybe
somebody had put some of these traps out
there that had but yeah I'm just saying
that was another possibility that I had
never occurred to me very unlikely um
but yeah somebody kind of said that too
uh along the same lines some of the
symptoms also kind of sound like strick
nine
poisoning um
which uh causes death by respiratory or
Cardiac Arrest um because the muscles
that you use for breathing like start
spasming and can't move that's slower
more lingering no yeah well it depends
on the dose uh it depends on the dose um
you can kill somebody very slowly um no
that's arsenic actually that you can do
the slow thing strick n is usually and
actually I've heard strick n is like one
of the worst ways how are you going to
get that into five people that's what I
mean I'm just not sure because strick
nine yes it's naturally occurring it's
not a weapon though but I kind of feel
like that would suggest that somebody
like act like poisoned them or it was in
their food or in their water or
something like that now strick n is used
as a pest control thing like to kill
gophers and stuff so
uh maybe they were kind of like foraging
in the area and like some then something
got on the mushroom because they were
foraging for mushrooms and things like
that so they could have poisoned
themselves that way I mean you know it's
like I said it could have
happened uh Dying by natural stuff
usually it's slower that's what I'm
saying a lot of vomiting and stuff you
know it's coming you feel you feel very
[__] sick this this H hit
instantly that's a weapon all right
nerve agents are weapons all right they
are they are bug spray for humans it's
their job to persist in an area or to be
delivered somewhere to have minimal
contact with a human being and it kills
them as quickly as possible that's what
VX was made to do had chemist trying to
figure that [__] out how do we kill
these people with these [__] poison
gas something that's just ta tailored
for it and man having five people just
just die all at once six people the six
people just
die within minutes of each
other by no visible means that means
that means a very minute amounts of and
she didn't mention smelling anything
weird either it's odorless and colorless
okay yeah that's part of the weapon okay
man no that's that's VX or that other
improved VX she's talking about that's a
nerve agent hell yeah na yeah that's
what it is that was built to kill people
and that's what you saw there they just
lost they they got they they lost
control over it
somehow some of it got up high in the
atmosphere or something and blew down
blew up got caught up in a in a draft
and then blew back down and hit somebody
and it was kind of sticking together in
an invisible [__] cloud or it was on
the ground or blowing through the trees
or something a little bit of it and it
it got six of them but not the seventh
something like that yeah n
this oh I ate something or we breathed
in some I'll get into there's more Stu
that's going to be
too that's going to have a lot of mixed
results natural Venoms tend to have like
you know or natural poisonings like
things from things like plants and mold
spores well because people's
physiologies are different so everyone's
going to react to it in a different way
in a different way in a different time
FR yeah and it's going to take different
amount of time so it's just it's not
reliable this whatever did this to these
kids was [__] reliable which tells me
it's a weapon that's kind of what I was
thinking too because like I said yeah
there's a possibility it could have been
natural like I said somebody brought up
strick n somebody brought up Mercury
like maybe they caught some fish that
had like mercury in it and stuff like
that but it's just kind of like because
that does CA cause similar symptoms they
all got exposed at the same time and
they all died at the same time that's a
weapon yeah
snakes can't do that snake bites can't
do that drinking [__] cyanide is not
going to do that it's going to take time
well yeah if it's a lot of concentration
but you didn't see them drink and they'd
all have to be drinking at the same time
that's another thing BEC okay so that's
like the next kind of theory which is
kind of related um some people have
talked about maybe uh the water was
contaminated that they were drinking um
so just like in the last one like maybe
it was some kind of nerve gas or
something like that but it was brought
down by the rain but also maybe the
hikers consumed it in when they drank
water now I will note that there's kind
of a lake that's upam from where they
were called Lake B Bal I think it's
called Bal but well it's b a y Ka oh
with a y yeah there's a y a a l yeah I
mean I would have said it like that if
there wasn't a y in it but there's a y
there word called B well I know that but
it's not the same place all right so um
so yeah so there's this Lake and this
lake has been um used for essentially
toxic waste dumping since I believe the
1960s um and so it's possible that the
heavy rains over the last couple of days
may have washed some of the toxic waste
from this Lake down into where they were
filling their cantens from and maybe
they all drank water with breakfast at
the same time and so the [__] all
started affecting them at the same time
you know what I mean because there was a
bunch of chlorine in there there's a
bunch of other [__] um because there was
a bunch of factory runoff there was a
bunch of other kind of crap in there I
don't remember what all they were doing
up there but they were pouring all kind
of like [__] waste in
there um so it's possible that in this
scenario maybe Valentina didn't drink as
much water or she got water from
someplace else than they did or
something like that um it's and the
thing about it too is that maybe
um you know I maybe see I see I think
when they did the autopsies I don't
think I don't know if like the KGB or
whoever like came in and told them hey
don't specifically look for
poison or don't test the blood like
James naap said but maybe they just
didn't do their due diligence you know
what I mean they're just like ah they it
was hypothermia the end you know what I
mean they didn't really like look for
any contaminants because they just
didn't really seem to I don't
know but the thing about it is if it was
from the water though like you said
anything that's
natural would affect everybody at a
different time so the fact that
everybody kind of died and that's kind
of going into the next Theory which was
they ate something poisonous nothing
another thing is is that there let's say
they drank something out of the pond the
pond had some nerve agent in it that P
if it had nerve agent in there that pond
would be filled with [__] dead frogs
and Dead Fish Flo up at the surface
didn't notice that it would kill
everything in there yeah I mean you
wouldn't think you'd want to drink out
of that it's like oh hey look at all the
dead fish [__] dead fish fla on the
surface not drink if there's enough of
it in there to kill you when you fill up
a canteen and drink it out of there that
means that where you're filling up there
going to be dead Tad poles and [__]
yeah creatures [__] everywhere so uh
no I ain't going to buy that it wasn't
water born it was airborn I kind of feel
like and when they and guarantee you
when they called this [__] in they knew
what it was they sent it down KGB down
there yeah a couple days ago we shot off
some [__] VX or months ago or
whatever it was yeah we were shooting
off some VX rounds about 100 miles away
that's probably what that is they would
have [__] clamped that [__] down they
would have shut everybody up he said
don't go up there man give it a couple
[__] weeks to [__] fall apart to
Decay it's totally polluted yeah that
[__] poison there's poison on them sorry
that was that was from 16 Candles yeah
that's what it is though that's what you
I'm telling that's what it is it's just
all it's all lining up yeah James says
uh Lake ball is the largest freshwat
lake in the world in terms of water
volume yeah I remember hearing that
actually but yeah it's uh again totally
polluted they just been they've been
dumping uh waste in there since 1966 I
believe maybe earlier but yeah uh so
yeah um so there are also theories like
I said they maybe ate something
poisonous this is kind of interesting I
don't believe this is the case either
but this is also kind of an interesting
Theory um so leod Milla was uh a forager
and she that was one of the survivalist
things that she taught her
uh her people you know what I mean her
students like how a forage for edible
stuff in the
wilderness and so it was hypothesized
that maybe she had picked some of the
wrong kind of mushrooms like and eaten
them and you know some bad [__]
happening not necessarily that the
mushrooms well I don't know not
necessarily the mushrooms were poison
but also maybe the they were kind of
like um you know yeah like magic
mushrooms and um one thing that I not
like one thing that I read said that
that if they were magic mushrooms that
caused hallucinations like a very common
Hallucination is seeing people cry blood
which I thought was kind of interesting
I don't know if that's the case but I
just read that somewhere Sounds full
like [__] well yeah like what I said
um so yeah it's in this scenario it's
like yeah maybe they ate the wrong kind
of mushrooms and either were tripping
their balls off or it or they were
poisonous and then they later died of
hypothermia exposure or whatever
um and in this scenario Valentina might
have lived because she didn't eat them
or had a higher tolerance or what have
you you know she would have reported she
saw him eat mushroom that's what I mean
I I kind of feel like she would have um
thing and the thing about it too is that
as experienced a survivalist as l Miller
was I find it extremely unlikely that
she would
have one picked the wrong kind of
mushrooms and two like fed people
mushrooms that she wasn't like sure that
they were completely safe you know what
I mean cuz usually people that are into
doing that kind of stuff they're pretty
careful about it and the first guy went
down because he started screaming it's
the first he started screaming start
taking [__] off and well I don't know if
he took [__] off but he started
screaming and then he probably took his
pack off he basically just um started
convulsing he started convulsing and
blood started coming out of his or so
there isn't any of this he's eating the
mushrooms and then lat they're saying
that they ate the muss at breakfast time
like 20 minutes earlier yeah so he's
there is what would have happened if it
was mushrooms he would have been eating
them and then s 15 20 minutes later he'd
be like I don't feel so good then they'd
all go yeah I don't feel too good either
then they would probably start throwing
up and they were going those mushrooms
were bad it wouldn't have gone down that
way wouldn't be instant convulsions and
dead within a few minutes no no just
sorry I just don't believe that here was
another kind of interesting thing and I
saw this brought up on a couple of
documentaries some didn't mention it
but um you know I don't think this had
anything to do necessarily with how they
died or anything but I just thought it
was kind of interesting so as I said
like leonilla was a big forager and her
and the others had been foraging uh Rose
root which is also called Golden root um
the scientific name is Rola
Rosa and uh so they had been collecting
that on the mountain while they were
going now this is supposedly like a good
source of nutrients and it's supposed to
uh like alleviate fatigue and altitude
sickness and various other things um
though this claim is not scientifically
verified but this is supposedly some
miracle drug that can do all this cure
cancer and all this other kind of [__]
um I although I will note the plant is
perfectly edible you can totally eat it
um you can eat the leaves you can eat
the chotes uh you can eat them raw
they're kind of bitter um or you can
cook them like and do the same kind of
[__] that you would do with spinach uh
so some people put them in salads and
stuff like that um so so I kind of feel
like some things I saw were kind of
maybe implying that maybe people had a
bad reaction to the Rose root or more
likely that maybe Valentina was the only
one to eat it and they gave her some
kind of protection from whatever it was
that happened to the other people um cuz
it's not real clear if any of the others
ate it um Valentina did but I don't know
if the others did now they did find a
big bag of it in lud milla's pack but it
might have been because she was G to
sell it later because it's actually like
a pretty high demand product like to put
in uh supplements and things like that
and it kind of commanded a high price so
if you went up there and kind of picked
some you could like sell it and like
make some money so she might have been
doing that so they don't know if she ate
it but some people have said that maybe
because Valentina ate that maybe that
protected her from whatever it was I
don't know now I will note too and this
is kind of sad that this happened
because in the wake of this
happening um Leo Mill I feel like got a
lot of
blame from people who thought cuz
remember how I said she was kind of a
hard ass yeah they believed that she was
like pushing her hi the hikers too hard
like they were just teenagers blahy blah
like some well I mean you know the
youngest one was 15 and then you know
they weren't that young you know what
I'm saying um but these people have
argued oh she was wearing them out and
she's like making them go on too little
food and all this other stuff pointing
to the autopsy that said that they had
Pro deficiencies like on the verge of
starvation and blah blah which I don't
think that's the case um now both
Valentina and L milla's other students
uh have come out like defending her
they're like look she knew her [__] um
she never would have done anything to
harm anybody that was in her charge um
and she was always like real strict
about making sure that everybody had
sufficient food for the number of
calories they'd be burning every day you
know what I mean like she figured out
how far far are we walking every day
like how many calories does this person
need like and would make sure that
everybody would pack that amount of
calories like at least and Valentina in
her later interview specifically said we
ate hot food four times a day and every
time we stopped to rest we always had
snacks they're like we always we had
chocolate we had onions we had beets we
had just all this kind of like cereals
all kind of stuff so we had stuff to eat
like all the time nobody was starving it
was fine you know what I mean so but
like I said I kind of feel like a lot of
people kind of blamed yod Milla like it
was her fault um and the thing about it
is that they were really only out for 3
or 4 days and I feel like that's not
really long enough for like true
malnutrition to set in um you know
protein deficiency over that many days
yeah it could make you more vulnerable
to other things like altitude sickness
or whatever so sure that could have been
a factor but I just don't think that was
a factor I mean like I said said these
were experienced hikers they had plenty
of food with them um they seemed like
they knew what they were doing and you
know none of the other hikers that she
had ever been on a journey with ever
said oh she made us like starve or
anything like that that seems like
really stupid so I don't know I just
don't think that's the case but liad
Milla did get a lot of [__] like after
this happened like people blaming her
you know and Valentina did say that they
had they had food they were eating just
fine they had enough protein it was [__]
like you know it was fine so
Valentina um after she you know was
rescued and everything um she told what
what happened to the police and then she
basically moved away and like just
started a new life uh she said I don't
want to talk about it which like I said
you can't [__] blame her you Jesus
Christ I can't imagine seeing that
happen in front of your face um you know
she said I just don't want to relive
that nightmare she did talk about it
again in I believe it was 2019 she gave
like an interview to a magaziner with
whatever but she's like I'm this is the
only other time I want to talk about it
and I just don't want to think about it
anymore cuz yikes you know what I mean
now she has said uh at least according
to that interview she thought that it
was um kind of the freezing rain was
kind of the main
factor um you know so I don't really
know she seems to subscribe more to like
the hypothermia or the weather thing
where everyone got really cold but I
don't know I don't know like I said it
really does seem like I did see a
YouTube comment on underneath uh one of
the documentaries about it and this
person said and this is a quote it says
as an experienced Mountaineer I can
vouch for a condition whereby if
temperatures drop enough and given the
wind faces the correct direction the air
can freeze in your Airways literally
crystallizing your lungs to the point
where you feel like you're suffocating
causing you to cough causing you to
cough blood while also making you feel
like you're overheating this could
explain why they had removed clothes and
had coughed up blood is extremely
painful way to die but very Poss
possible this could have been the cause
not impossible um if you know given the
unusual weather conditions and like I
said Valentina does seem to subscribe to
that like she thought maybe that's what
happened but I don't really know I've
never heard of that I never heard of
that either there getting all kinds of
cold wind blowing on us in Korea never
had never had anything like that happen
and she was fcking freezing cold now Zan
wanted to know he's asked what can we
explain the friend biting Valentina yeah
nerve agent would nerve agent make
someone act out that way yeah yeah yeah
I kind of feel like yeah anything that
would make you glitch out like that
would make you like C would cause you to
it's confused thinking yeah blurry
vision lack of being able to swallow
slurred speech you just start to become
a [__] zombie and then uh convulsions
and death that's that's it that sounds
just like [__] nerve agent that's why
yeah and I kind and the girl like
bashing her head against The Rock too
yeah because obviously they weren't
thinking clearly yeah you're not
thinking clearly like something
descended on them and they all started
like flipping out starts [__]
malfunctioning because of [__] the
ner you know your nerves are all
shutting down you know it's it gets into
your skin or it gets into your lungs and
it just starts shutting all the nerves
off convulsions and nothing makes sense
everything's just firing randomly then
you suffocate cuz you can't breathe
you're not breathing because that takes
commands to expand your chest and
[__] you you you you're you become so
discombobulated you can't even take a
breath you're you're not coordinated
enough just eats you up and your
thinking is out the window as soon as
they're doing things like biting noses
or B trying to bite or speaking real
slur and everything they're not really
there anymore they're on their way
out yeah so it's not human behavior and
like I said it wasn't just the biting
thing it was that other girl like
bashing her head against the rest too I
think that was Tatiana they did said the
slurred speech they couldn't make make
out what she was saying that's that's
that's nerve agent well I don't remember
saying that but no I thought you said
that one girl tried to say something but
nobody could understand what she was
saying no I didn't say that I thought
you said that okay said they couldn't
quite make it out okay no that was later
on when I was talking about when they
found Valentina but that's because she
was freaked out not because she was like
but yeah I mean like I said the only I
think the most mysterious thing about it
is how Valentina was unaffected
completely yeah if this indeed was nerve
gas which I think it was everything
about this says that it was nerve gas
like I said I don't think they were
deliberately Poisoned With nerve gas
like I don't think they were tested on
or anything like that not saying that
hasn't happened but I don't think that
happened in this case I think it was
accidental accidental discharge I think
that they had either like you said
accidentally discharge it like sooner or
they had been testing it like earlier at
some earlier time like a few months ago
or something and it just because of the
bad weather it kind of like washed down
to where they were like into some kind
of pocket and they just happened to like
walk into it but like I said I'm not
really sure how Valentina escaped
because she was there she was right
there with them so she was either she
must be like the luckiest [__] person
in the world yeah to like not have been
affected at all because nerve gas it's
not a kind of thing where cuz like you
said like natural poisons some people
can survive that [__] I mean some people
it'll kill them some people not it's
just like illness you know what I mean
because everyone's pH physiology is
different so some people are more
resistant but you know a nerve gas like
you said is specifically designed to
kill you to kill people yeah um so it's
going to kill people it's not nobody's
going to like be immune to that or
whatever it is literally bug spray for
humans for humans what it is raid for
humans and I think they were using it in
some area a lot of times you know
they'll want to test shelf lifes you
know what I mean make sure that c what
they were using on on on the Contra all
right was stuff that they gave to the S
they gave it to the sandinistas and they
were using the Soviet hind helicopters
with rocket pods rocket launching pods I
think it it's probably like 40
millimeter rockets in a [__] cluster
pod and had VX in those they would shoot
those rockets off in a big volley and
they'd hit up on a mountain inside the
jungle you know it's like Predator type
[__] they'd [__] hit trees and it all
pop open puff it be like little puffs of
[__] smoke that [__] go clear and
then if any of that blows on you or gets
on you you're dead man that's how they
were that's they were using that all the
Soviets were testing it in uh on the uh
they getting it to the sanis so they
could use it on on the contr in
Nicaragua it was that Nicaragua or
Venezuela I thought it was Nicaragua but
Nicaragua I I could be wrong so uh I
thing what happened is is they were
doing something like they'll want to
test how long the shelf life is they
might set up a
range they'll put some targets out there
and then they'll put some special kinds
of papers and chemical detectors out
there in the damn Target Zone fly a
helicopter with the oldest Rockets they
got maybe those Rockets been sitting
around for 10 years and they'll shoot
them off there and then
[__] get a reading back on All Those
sensors to make sure that the that the
VX is still good how you know how much
is it degraded you know they want to
know you know cuz usually that [__] is
not shelf stable not not long term so
let's say they're testing like that in
an area 20 mies 30 miles 50 miles maybe
from this place yeah which they were I
mean you know they they pretty much know
that there's storms going on and a big
gust of wind catches some of that stuff
yeah all right it real windy and then
there's mountains there it GS over the
mountains and it's [__] doing weird
[__] that you know like some kind like a
Gulf Stream a stream of air well they
just happen to walk through a stream
[__] 50 mil away it's got a little
bit in it and maybe it's intermittent
yeah you know what I mean like I said
maybe it's just little pockets little
pockets of it in a stream in an
Airstream coming up over the mountains
you know and it comes down a little
blast gets five of them or six of them
but not the seventh she might have been
a distance there might have been
distance in between them or just sheer
look it might have been that it wasn't
very concentrated by the time it got to
it was you know real
weak but that doesn't mean anything with
some of these [__] yeah nerve AG like
I said she was super lucky just a little
bit can kill you well evidently she
avoided it somehow cuz I don't think she
really even described having any
symptoms from it yeah she was in the
right place at the right time not to to
to to to dodge it you know but it was an
accident she didn't know it's it's
odorless it's colorless it's invisible
then it hit the other ones and it got
them all around the same time which that
that checks out the nerve within minutes
that checks out the nerve AO only a
weapon does that not some kind of
natural well some spores blue yeah it
sounds good but it's not going to be
that reliable some of them are some
it'll kill some of them maybe other ones
it'll just get real sick other ones
it'll die but it might take two or three
days you don't know it's right it's not
something yeah like you said something
natural is more likely to like not be as
it's not real reliable it's not potent
this was [__] designed as a weapon it
gets you you dead dead than [__] bug
spray for humans whatever this was it
was designed to kill humans you you know
what's kind of interesting to me even
though I don't think that Valentina has
ever said that she thought it was nerve
gas maybe they told her not to say that
I don't really know yeah but um she her
behavior on the T at the time that it
happened does seem to suggest that she
knew that there that it was something in
the area because she was basically like
I got to get out of this [__] area we
said she couldn't talk for a while huh
she was well she well that was because
of trauma who
knows yeah may maybe that was very very
weak nerve agent poisoning possibly and
it took her a little while to [__]
shake it off so maybe she did get some
yeah maybe so I never thought real small
amount not enough to kill you you know
and it was just enough to
[__] make her brain go slightly
Haywire she just kind of withdraw with
withdrew back into kind of a zombie like
State you know panic and then after a
while she kind of snapped out of it cuz
I mean she had to have her [__] together
cuz she survived all by herself in the
wilderness for 4 days before they found
her let's say you got a survivable dose
of
it you're the best thing to do is to
keep moving because it's going to
[__] filter it out through your
kidneys yeah drink water and keep moving
try to get try to get it out of your
system sweat it out through your pores I
mean the human body can put up with a
lot of [__] and can survive a lot of
[__] yeah but like you said these nerve
agents are super potent and we're
specifically designed right to kill
everyone they came in contact with and
what you're talking
about maybe killed the other ones maybe
it wouldn't even be a single drop like
if you were to take a drop if you were
to take a needle and drop it in that
fluid it's kind of like oil and if you
drop it so you have a little single drop
hanging off the end of that needle how
much on bit it was one quarter of that
that got on those people might have been
one quarter of that spread out in in a
Mist right you know what I'm talking
about little tiny droplets or you can't
even see them well that girl might have
got one tenth of that drop yeah and she
L
survived That's how little it takes it
sets up chain reactions and [__] it's
made to kill you San said the video I
saw said that the ukrainians found her
acting strangely and washing her clothes
in the river so maybe she did get a
slate days yeah maybe yeah they did say
she was acting kind of weird the the one
thing that I thought was weird was that
like I said she seemed to have the
wherewithal to survive for four days by
herself she seemed to know I got to
follow the power lines and then she gets
down there and the village is abandoned
she's like oh there's a river so I'm
going to follow the river so she had her
[__] together enough for that yeah she
did hang a shirt or a sleeping bag in a
tree because she's like I want to make
like a flag or something like that so
people will see it but then the weird
thing is that when the kayakers passed
her she didn't say anything to them
which I thought was kind of odd cuz she
did seem to have her [__] together
enough to know what to do like to
survive and she seemed to remember [__]
but it was just kind of like why didn't
she be like hey can you help me or
whatever she didn't they just like
passed her and she just like looked at
them it could that might be evidence of
so maybe cuz I thought that was kind of
odd you would think that she'd be like
unless she just thought that they
weren't real well she was Dazed that's
what I mean maybe not only the trauma
maybe it was the chemicals yeah I I
hadn't really thought of that but yeah
it's possible she did get like a tiny
little cuz it seems crazy that she got
nothing yeah she probably something that
killed six people in minutes like that
confused thinking maybe that's what it
was yeah I just can't imagine like that
poor [__] girl man she was only like
17 years old and to just like be on a
hike and be every normal with your
friends and stuff like that and then
like a minute later everyone's bleeding
from their [__] eyes and like
dropping to the ground holy [__] [__]
yeah she probably did get some I
couldn't imagine like what that would be
like and then like to then then they're
all dead and then you have to like
[__] survive in the wilderness 4 days
by yourself and you don't know where you
are and [__] like that God that must
have been [__] horrifying I don't
really blame her for like not wanting to
talk about it imagine the was it the
park Rangers or the cops who was it that
handled it cops probably right yeah they
went to the police imagine the cops
probably uh put that out to the police
station man this is some weird [__] that
happened look at this didn't happen
those cops were like yeah that sounds
like nerve agent and then they might
have [__] called this the KGB it's
probably who they'd call or the local
military base but then they would have
sent the KGB they probably would have
called us some kind of secret police KGB
yeah you think saying man um because
those guys are mostly had military
training they would have recognized for
nerve agent symptoms yeah when she
started talking they would have said um
hang on a second we got to make a phone
a phone call KGB is like oh hold on
don't do nothing we we'll be right over
we know what she's talking about they
probably check the records yeah they
were just testing some of I think pretty
much anybody that knows anything about
anything like in the world as soon as
people started saying convulsing and
blood coming from the eyes everybody's
like oh nerve gas yeah you know what I
mean I feel like most people would
probably cops would the cops probably
would have known what that was if I
think almost everybody had a military
background in in the Soviet police you
know they did Army time they had to do
draft I don't think everybody got
drafted but they drafted a certain
amount a lot of people did though yes
they would have known they would have
known they' called the they would have
called the Soviet intelligence KGB say
uh this is what this girl's telling us
maybe maybe some nerve agent and it says
okay don't say nothing we'll be on we'll
be up there and they probably contacted
the local military base and were you
guys testing they're like yeah we were
testing just the other day but okay yeah
that's not too far from there all right
yeah don't worry about it we'll take
care of it yeah they died of hypothermia
yeah hypothermia that's what happened
and a heart attack yeah hypothermia and
a heart attack maybe they thought they
could say that the that the one woman
died of a heart attack cuz she was 41
years old oh she's practically she's
ancient you know I mean I don't know um
yeah Zan said it's horror movie type
stuff I you know what I'm surprised has
anybody made a horror movie about this
there is a movie about the Jacob's
Ladder what Jacob's Ladder no I mean
about this specific oh not this one no
there is a horror movie about the deaw
of pass incident well kind of it's
called Devil's Pass and um it's actually
not exactly about that it's about um
it's kind of found footage but it's like
about a group that goes there to
investigate it and then scary [__]
happens to them um I have a review of it
that I did a while back it's a pretty
okay movie although it gets a little
outlandish toward the end and I think
it's a little disrespectful toward the
people that that it actually happened to
but um thought you were talking about is
there any horror movies about the
military accidentally poison no no no I
said is there any horror movies about
this specific incident one there's un on
2B somewhere there's another old movie
from the '90s or ' 80s called Butterfly
Effect remember that one yeah yeah yeah
I remember that movie and uh it's a
weird ass horror movie about this
Vietnam veteran coming home to be become
a mailman and all kinds of weird [__]
happens to him no that's Jacob's Ladder
Jacob's Ladder that's right Jacob's
Ladder yeah Butterfly Effect is a
totally different right jcob ladder uh
and turns out uh that was from that he's
still in Vietnam he got hit with the
damn weaponized P
alert he's dead the whole time doesn't
matter that's an old movie I know um
[__] uh he got hit with uh weaponized
[__] LSD they were testing it on the
troops remember that yeah yeah that was
pretty good
one high desert said that movie is
really bad I'm I'm assuming he's talking
about the butterfly effect yeah I don't
know I don't even think you've seen the
movie The Butterfly Effect probably not
I don't know I saw it a long time ago
but yeah I don't remember that much
about it I've probably seen it and
forgot all about it Jacob's Ladder was
good though yeah Jacob's Ladder that's
that was from 1990 yeah Zan said this is
the country that tried to cover up a
nuclear meltdown so it's totally
plausible yeah I kind of feel like
that's what I don't like I said I don't
think that they sprayed these people
with nerve gas on purpose but I think
that as soon as she came and told her
story they knew exactly what it was
they're like yeah we're just going to
like make this disappear everyone died
of hypothermia just an accident the end
that's kind of what they did but I yeah
I think that's what that was I mean we
accidentally dropped an atomic bomb on
the United States yeah remember that we
should do a [__] show about that yeah
right yeah that might not be a very long
show but I'm just saying it's kind of an
interesting incident though I think it
was the Army Air Corp early ear early US
Air Force were transporting basically
like a like a tall boy or a fat boy
[__] atomic bomb they had it strapped
underneath [__] the belly of a bomber
and they accidentally dropped it it hit
in the middle of nowhere though I'm
surprised that only happened one time
yeah dropped to be honest and then they
went and checked it whoops and it had a
bunch of safeties on it but all of the
safeties had [__] rupt except one
only one safety one safety uh um
[__] kept it from blowing off blowing
up and I think it [__] tripped six
six of or something it almost went
off which yeah that's pretty scary s
said do a show on Military mishaps yeah
we probably should that should be fun
dropping atomic bomb on the United
States that was a good one it didn't go
off but like I said also we also lost
whole uh um nuclear
submarines with all their [__]
nuclear missiles they're sitting down
there at the bottom of the ocean well
see here's the it's like it hid that the
military just like everything else in
the world is run by humans and have you
met humans they're idiots yeah so you
know what I mean to varying degrees so I
mean you know they make mistakes
everybody makes mistakes you just go to
work one day and you kind of like are
not really feeling it and you [__]
something up and you just drop a nuclear
bomb on somebody yeah it was one of
those first generation nuclear
submarines might have been Nautilus I
don't know might or one of her sister
ships it [__] up and got set to the
bottom with all hands and all those
nuclear weapons they're sitting down
there now still sitting there but
they're in such deep water you can't get
them out to so we're notat I mean you
know yeah might have caused a Godzilla
situation we don't know
yeah yeah Zena said that has to be the
worst way to die talking about like
nerve gas I
mean the only good thing I can say about
it is at least it doesn't last
long but I think it makes man that must
be the worst [__] five minutes of
your [__] life though you get so
confused you don't know what's happening
I'm pretty sure I would hope because I
always thought and maybe not like I've
never been any through anything like so
traumatic that I had this happen but a
lot of times when you go through
something traumatic your brain just kind
of shuts down because a lot of people
I've known that have been through like
real bad um you know like traumas like
natural disasters or really bad like car
wrecks or something like that they said
well they don't even remember it
happening you know what I mean it's like
oh I just remember a few minutes before
and then I remember waking up in the
hospital they don't like remember
anything happening so I was like maybe
your brain has a thing where it's just
kind of like I'm just going to I'm just
going to take that out of there just
like help you out a little bit you know
what I mean yeah the military mishaps J
said it would be at least two shows it
might I might have to like pick some
good cases though that might be a fun
that might be a fun show to do we'll
kind of pick up well I don't know it it
might be kind of depressing too but like
I said the one where they accidentally
dropped the bomb at least the bomb
didn't go off and nobody got killed
right yeah no so it almost went off
that's just well yeah but had it gone
off I don't think anybody been killed
either cuz it was happened to be in an
area where was out MD nowhere so it was
just
like you know what I mean rather than oh
my God like the worst thing ever you
know what I mean but that's the thing
only in hindsight can we say it's like
oh it's not it's just kind of funny I'm
sure there's a lot of [__] that's even
much worse than that that's happened
we'll never oh I imagine I imagine so
cuz you know they've done like a lot of
[__] up experimentation and stuff like
that too although maybe that should be a
separate show cuz we've done a show like
on Mad Science I want to do another Mad
Science Show because there was a lot of
[__] we left off about that like weird
military experience and [__] like that
but I don't know we'll get into that so
uh are
you uh jany said Tom are nerve agents
like agent orange no agent orange is a
defoliant yeah it was uh to kill okay
round up what you have today yeah it
killed plants just killed plants they
were just trying to defoliate Vietnam or
certain strips of it that way you could
see where the trails were where they
were [__] transporting weapons and
walking they were trying to open it up
so they could see it and uh they' hit it
with Agent Orange try to bust all that
[__]
down thing is they didn't know it at the
time it was it was carcinog gentic yeah
and it uh did DNA damage in men and a
lot of them had U uh mentally [__]
children [__] up children after that
yeah so it didn't kill them it wasn't
like a nerve gas yeah cuz it was just
meant as a defoliant but it had like
lingering effect had lingering effects
that they didn't know about or they said
they didn't know about I don't think
they knew I don't think they knew about
now Roundup is I think
the same thing it's just a slightly
different version that they claim is is
safer yeah the [__] you spray but there
were some guys [__] they had one of
these guys from [__] di chemicals or
whatever who made that [__] and uh there
were some lawyers there they were
fighting it they were trying to get that
[__] banned and the the guys know it's
fully safe it's totally safe and they
said you could drink that and it' be
okay and they poured a big don't tell
anybody that dude dude poured a dude
dude poured a glass that [__] in into a
[__] and hand it to him says well
drink it then and he wouldn't drink it
says if it's safe drink it he's like no
I can drink it yeah he's like
no but it's you know atrazine I guess is
what it's called yeah jenet said my
cousin died from it years after he got
back yeah yeah that's what I mean but
it's not a nerve agent of the same way
because a nerve agent is basically meant
to like kill people kill immediately and
animals you know they'll kill any any
mammal I said I'm not saying Asian
orange is great because it had like
lingering effects that they supposedly
didn't know about ahead of time but it
wasn't intended to kill people that
wasn't its function supposed to be
harmless you know they were walking in
it they they'd go into those defoliated
areas after been hit with agent orange
and they were you know doing Patrols in
there and [__] bedding down and
sleeping in on in the defoliated areas
and it had uh [__] you know basically
industrial strength Roundup basically
what it was but it bad for you but it
was worse for your children you know
that's really who did a lot of genetic
damage on
them yeah and that's the thing it's
like the shitty thing about a lot of
those chemicals that came out uh back
then is that a lot of the worst effects
of it were in the Next Generation like
it wouldn't necessarily do anything to
you or it might but not until years
later so they didn't really test for
that and they for sure did not test for
like [__] that would cause birth defects
and stuff like that that's basically
what it caused cuz look at all that
stuff what was that stuff that used to
be um the theide that's what I was
thinking toide like that that was
supposedly safe yeah it was yeah they
gave it to pregnant women for morning
sickness but it like they didn't know
until later they don't give it to people
anymore obviously but um but they used
to and it caused like birth defects it
is a default setting do not
trust these me do not trust the medical
company
or chemical companies or like that
[__] trust them they were they were
just trying to get huge contracts make a
[__] ton of money but in the military
industrial
complex maybe on paper they knew yeah
this is probably pretty low risk this
shouldn't hurt you but they weren't
willing to drink glasses of it when they
said it'd be safe no genetic damage and
[__] [__] you up later [__] up your
children in terms of Agent
Orange yeah I don't trust him and that's
what I mean even trying to make money
man yeah the and that's the thing even
if they didn't intend to like kill
people they were like well we did test
for some [__] but like I said they're
going to test for like immediate [__]
does it kill anybody immediately no it's
probably fine then but like I said they
don't really they're not going to do
like a [__] 50-year longitudinal
study where it's like oh well does it
cause birth defects in the Next
Generation or something and that's what
a lot of those things do well it didn't
it didn't on the damn tis flies that we
tested on it didn't do anything to you
know the rats right but you know rats
don't live that that long anyway what
happens to a person who lives you know
nearly 70 80 years you know what do it
do to them you know I so I just uh
they're like we don't have the money for
these [__] 50 years you know what I
mean they're all big corporations and
the most important thing for them is
what it looks like on the [__] next
quarter sheet you know what I mean on
their on their sales and earning sheet
that's all they care about yeah they
don't want to get sued they'll probably
take something like that that agent
orange molecule you know whatever or
whatever I don't know if it might have
been a compound of many molecules they
probably looked at that and they go well
do you think that hurt theyd probably
ask a few doctors do you think that
molecule would hurt a human and they
probably no I shouldn't you know that's
that's that's probably shouldn't
shouldn't yeah it should be okay it
should be okay yeah it's fine it's fine
Zan said there's an ongoing case right
now about whether Roundup causes cancer
and autism I think it turns the frogs
gay
you heard about that yeah it doesn't
turn him gay though it makes them
uh makes them transexual basically more
hermaphroditic yeah they got more
hermaphroditic and then the males start
start trying to have mate with other
males it's
atrazine people spraying round up and
then the water runs off it goes into
pools and ponds where frogs live and it
[__] up their breeding cycle that
sounds like a 70s Eco horror waiting to
happen well they made some like that
does weird [__] to was about that and
here's another thing is is that all the
hormonal birth control women are taking
that's ended up in the water
table which can do things to people and
and animals because there's uh kind of
like estrogen mimicker type stuff that's
happening in there and other weird
chemicals everything you eat all you
know all this medicine that you take
ends up somewhere in the damn septic
sewage systems and then eventually back
into water
tables so you got to be careful with
everything I mean you do but it's like
in a way I'm kind of like yeah I kind of
worry about it but then in another way
I'm like yeah but like a hundred years
ago they were like drinking sewage water
they years ago so it's like it's
probably the thing is with the birth
control
runoff probably only a factor outside
really big cities in a in a sparsely
populated area like this there's not
going to be enough women peeing in the
area there's not enough women for it to
[__] make a difference to get get a
dose into somebody you know like I said
I it's going to be Big Al and it might
only be theoretical like theoretically
all the sewage coming out of that City
should have x and x amount of chemicals
because of the birth control and then
the Cleaning Solutions and then you know
[__] motor oils a certain amount of
motor oil is going to be in there you
know there all kinds of weird [__] but
it may not actually make its way back
into the human population it might go
out to the sea or it might end up being
cycled down another place you don't
realize so it may not actually be
affecting people when it could but it's
just not it's not the runoff isn't
getting to them I don't know cuz that's
the thing it's like yeah there's a lot
of [__] like in our air and water and
stuff like that but it's just kind of
like it's probably so diluted that get I
mean there'd really have to be a large
concentration of it in one small area to
like really affect people and even if it
does I kind of feel like it probably
takes a really long time like so long
that you probably wouldn't even be able
to prove the connection if you had to
like I said it's a different thing where
you know there's obviously one area
where some gas was released and
everybody got sick like obviously but
just stuff like regular water and [__]
like that you know as long as you
probably filter it and you'll probably
be fine list and honestly I've been
drinking just regular ass tap water my
whole life you know what I mean yeah we
filter it now but I never used to I
never used to bother I used to just
drink it right out of the [__] think and
if you were to ask me is Round Up safe
I'm fine if you were to ask me if
Roundup was safe I'd say probably not
but I'm not drinking out of my lawn true
you know and uh I'm at a point in life
where I don't think it would affect my
lifespan I'm not using it every day yeah
now if you were working on a lawn crew
and you were young and you did 30 years
on a lawn crew then you probably then
you might want to worry because it's
like yeah the length of exposure how
much exposure you're getting to it stuff
like that like I said just drinking out
of a [__] faucet and [__] like that I
don't think that's going to affect you
too badly like I said I've done it my
whole life and I'm fine but it's just
kind of like depends where you live too
I have lived in other areas where I
drank out of the faucet and it tasted
really gross so I didn't so I just drank
bottled water instead but most of the
time it's fine you know I don't know I'm
not I don't worry about it all that much
like I said no one's drinking we're not
drinking poop water anymore at least
like they were back in the [__] day
or eel water
yeah eels would die in the damn [__]
pipes and rot in the pipes and people
drink the water like man it tastes funny
and then that was I think that was
Chicago where that was happening in the
late 1800s early 1900s and they found
out that yeah there was millions and
millions of
eels living in the [__] water system
and they were dying and rotting inside
the damn pipes and people were just
steady drinking whatever this tastes
pretty gross like it's water we still
got drink it cuz the the system why they
Dr beer they had no filtration they
would just take [__] fresh water and
pour it into the system and big objects
the size of [__] eels could get in it
they didn't filter
anything dumb but they didn't know what
they were doing they didn't know any
better they didn't know how to build
water systems back then like I said they
would like [__] they had like pools
of waste like human waste just sitting
around just sitting around and it's like
they somehow didn't see a problem with
that why is everybody getting sick gee I
wonder like you know what I mean it's
like why do you think Nature Made that
smell like that because they were just
kind of like yeah you might want to like
move away you
know uh yeah zanana said the worst water
to drink would be if you were in that
hotel where Alisa lamb died yeah and I
think some people did too they were
drinking they tasted it they say it was
terrible yeah and it's like then later
they found out there was a [__] dead
body in the water tank water GH yeah I
can't imagine I was just like man I
would brush my teeth for like [__] 48
hours straight and I would still like
want to throw some cute little dead
shinese girl floating in a damn water oh
man God can you imagine we were grossed
out by like our ice machine broke and
then Tom said oh I was cleaning it and I
found a gat in there we've been drinking
Gat ice and I was just kind of like eh
but you know it's like I don't care it's
a knat it's tiny but um yeah so that
doesn't gross me at at all but like the
fact of like [__] a corpse floating
in the water oh my God I can't imagine
uh James said he's heading out good
night yeah we're about to wrap it up as
well because it's been about 10 o'clock
and we've kind of gone through the case
y but yeah so um hopefully you guys
enjoyed this this was like I said this
was a topic I did not know about
previously so thank you very much zanada
for I think it was zand that um
recommended it because i' had never
heard of it before and it's uh super
weird and like weird weirder than de
love like I said because I'm pretty sure
Dia was just like an avalanche type
situation but uh but yeah so hopefully
you guys enjoyed it I'm probably don't
hold me to this but I'm probably going
to do uh stream tomorrow about a
Christmas horror film I'm actually going
to do Christmas Bloody Christmas because
I've already watched that and written up
a thing about it and everything like
that so I'm probably going to stream
that sometime tomorrow afternoon uh and
I might do another Christmas
movie that I might stream about on
Sunday I'm not entirely sure cuz I
haven't decided and I haven't watched it
yet but I might do one tomorrow if I
don't do it tomorrow then I'll I'll save
that until Sunday but we'll see how it
goes uh Zan said thanks for covering
this Jenny I I knew you'd do a detailed
analysis of it yeah like I said I got
super into it I went down a rabbit hole
like I watched like seven different
documentaries about it and like read all
these different like articles about it
and [__] like that and just that look
like accidental nerve Agent P that's
what I thought too I thought that's kind
of also the theory that I uh that I
subscribe to I think that's exactly what
happened and I think there was like a
little bit of a cover up
um Danny Rowling said cough cough to all
a good night I might actually do that
one um I think it might be on shutter
actually now that I'm thinking about it
I'll have to look I thought I saw it on
there but that might be another that was
another one that I was considering doing
so I might do that one too but we'll see
uh so yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by this evening thanks for super chats
and I might see you guys again tomorrow
but we will both see you again on Friday
night for the Sidetrack show which will
always be fun so hopefully you guys can
come for that and good I